bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver en direct pour suivre cette
émission spéciale consacrée aux
régionales sur figaro live nous allons
vous faire vivre tous les résultats de
ce second tour
je vous ferai découvrir les coulisses du
journal comment se préparent les pages
du quotidien que vous découvrirez en
kiosque demain et comment se préparent
les contenus que vous pouvez lire sur
lefigaro.fr
je vous présenterai des personnalités
piliers du figaro qui vous expliqueront
leurs rôles et leurs responsabilités
dans les dispositifs de ce soir mais
tout de suite je vous propose de
retrouver vincent roux il est en direct
depuis le grand plateau du figaro le
plateau haussmann aux côtés d'emmanuel
rivière qui est le directeur des études
politiques de l'institut sondage kantar
public
il sera rejoint un peu plus tard paris
yves thréard directeur adjoint de la
rédaction et puis guillaume roquette
pardon directeur de la rédaction du
figaro magazine
ensemble ils feront l'analyse des
résultats de ce scrutin
je vous laisse la main vincent roux à
tout à l'heure
merci charlotte barioz dennebouy et vous
retrouverez charlotte barillon dennebouy
des tout à l'heure dans quelques minutes
et également ici dans ce grand studio
haussmann du figaro bienvenue et en
étant heureux d'être avec vous on est en
direct c'est figaro live on attend vos
commentaires on attend vos questions et
on déposera donc ce soir à emmanuel
rivière bonsoir emmanuel race un merci
d'être de retour très heureux des
garrots et bien nous aussi on est
heureux et les internautes on est
heureux de retrouver également les
internautes du figaro on va prendre vos
questions commenté également donc cette
cette soirée soirée particulière à bien
des égards c'est la dernière
consultation électorale avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 c'est une
soirée électorale qui survient après
bien des surprises en particulier
emmanuel la surprise de l'abstention qui
a été plus forte que prévu la semaine
dernière et qui devrait ce soir ce se
stabiliser autour de 65 5% 65% soit 65
165 points 5 % donc un petit peu moins
mais pas tellement moins que la semaine
dernière a tellement moins et surtout ça
change pas le constat de la semaine
dernière qu'ils étaient non seulement
celui d'une abstention plus forte que
prévu dans des enquêtes qu'elle lançait
déjà eux-mêmes une abstention historique
et donc une abstention qu'on peut
qualifier d' accidentelle en fait on est
dans des niveaux d'abstention sur une
élection nationale un patient
accidentelle ou une participation
accidentelle ou en tout cas
bref il ya quelque chose qui est cassé
puisque je pense que peu de mots sont
trop forts pour qualifier le message qui
a été envoyé par un certain nombre de
lecteurs qui disent tout simplement ben
en fait ça ne nous concerne pas en tout
cas ça ne nous intéresse pas parce que
lorsqu'on a des abstentions massive à
des scrutins nationaux législatives en
2010 est régionale auparavant
européennes souvent on plafonnait avec
les européennes à des abstentions qui
approchait les 60% là on les avait elle
aigrement dépassées et c'est à nouveau
le cas et donc 65% ce serait aller une
progression peut-être deux points par
rapport à la semaine dernière
reportons-nous six en cinq ans et demi
en arrière décembre 2015 premier tour on
avait été surpris par un regain de
participation n'a pas trop l'habitude de
commenter cela les soirs d'élection
second tour on passe de 50 58 % de
participation
donc on est donc de 50% d'abstention à
42% d'abstentions
donc il y avait une espèce de sursaut
après le sursaut dans l'idée qu' il y
avait quelque chose qui se joue est
décidément dans ces régionales que ce
second tour était un tour décisif et
qu'il était donc mobilisateur peut pas
dire que ce soit pas du tout ce qui
s'est produit
simplement ça s'est produit dans ce
cercle restreint réduit des électeurs
qui se sont intéressés aux régionales il
ya un sursaut de deux points et non pas
de 8 points
la presse qu'on commence à voir de la
participation en tout cas à partir de la
participation à 17h dans les régions on
voit que ce sursaut s'est produit dans
certaines régions plus que dans d'autres
peut-être en raison de l'enjeu mais pas
de manière spectaculaire pour parler
clair le là où il y as on note en tous
les cas la plus forte participation à
17h c'est en provence alpes côte d'azur
où on a une participation aux alentours
de 32
32 9% un petit peu plus de 32 9% et
al'inverse c'est en bretagne quand on
observe le moindre le moins de
participation en bretagne qui avait -
enfin davantage voté ou qui s'était
relativement moins abstenus que la
plupart des autres régions ce qui est
assez classique d'ailleurs c'est un
élément intéressante cette analyse de la
participation dans cette structure
géographique dans cette structure
sociologique
rien n'a changé sauf que les régions qui
d'habitude sont particulièrement
civiques mais là on était elle aussi
marqué par une abstention massive donc
on va toujours plus à l'ouest qu'à l'est
sont pour votre toujours plus chez les
personnes âgées que chez les jeunes en
mode toujours plus chez les personnes
diplômées que chez les personnes sans
diplôme mais on voit beaucoup moins
qu'on ne l'a jamais fait dans des
élections en france sous la vème
république
on voit justement revenir sur ces sur
ces questions là je salue rowland emma
qui nous rejoint en ce moment en direct
sur le site du figaro vous pouvez
également nous suivre en direct sur
youtube merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
roland nous demande après la première
claque électorale de dimanche y
aura-t-il la seconde
eh bien on vient de répondre je pense
roland à la question que vous posez
notamment sur la participation
effectivement qui serait un légèrement
supérieures sont les premières
projections à celle de
dimanche de dimanche dernier mais pour
l'instant même si c'est ainsi c'est un
sursaut comme le dit emmanuel ce n'est
pas un sursaut comparable à celui des
élections de 2002 2015 de décembre 2015
qui avait vu déjà un premier regard de
participation au premier tour et de 8.1
différentiel de 8 points en faveur de la
participation au deuxième tour
une autre chose est ce que ce regain de
participation léger regain de
participation peut avoir un effet un
impact sur les sur les sur les résultats
sur les projections qui sont faites
ou bien c'est enfin amplifier des
tendances qu'on a vu au premier tour
entre les cas selon les projections qui
ont été faites cette semaine il faut
être extrêmement modestes en fait une
élection à près de 70% 65% ce soir
d'abstention ce qui se produit nature à
l'autre on peut pas trop le décrire
parce que c'est quasiment sans référence
on a une référence qui lui permet de
faire des hypothèses sont les élections
partielles
ces législatives partielles parfois des
cantonales ou parfois même des
municipales partielles ou moins à des
taux de participation extrêmement
faibles alors là on retrouve quelque
chose assez familier avec deux électeurs
sur trois parfois trois électeur sur
quatre qui négligent et dans ces
élections là ce qui se produit
habituellement c'est que le les
électeurs du second tour ressemble aux
électeurs du premier tour c'est assez
logique là dedans c'est une élection
nationale donc on ne peut pas exclure
l'hypothèse qui est un vrai brassage
entre les deux tours ce qui n'exclurait
pas un certain nombre de surprises et
pour l'instant ce sursaut de
participation le fait qu'on veut
davantage au second tour compromis en
tout cas c'est grand classique pour les
élections régionales ce qui n'est pas
classique ce sont les niveaux auxquels
ça se fait eh bien on va continuer à
suivre sa emmanuel vous êtes avec nous
toute la soirée pour commenter pour
analyser ses résultats en direct et puis
pour nour préciser les enjeux et yves
thréard nous rejoindra donc à partir de
19h30
et puis à 20h30 ce sera le tour de
guillaume roquette on est en direct ici
dans le grand studio haussmann du figaro
jusqu'à
22h et puis après vous pourrez suivre en
direct notre soirée électorale en
partenariat avec la chaîne publique et
avec la chaîne parlementaire assemblée
nationale et public sénat présenté par
rebecca fitoussi et brigitte boucher
pour l'instant on continue de préparer
la une du figaro et je vous propose
justement d'aller là où se prépare se
concoctent les maquettes de l'édition
papier que vous allez retrouver dans les
prochaines heures en pdf et dans vos
kiosques
on retrouve pour sa charlotte baryons de
ne bouge
et oui merci vincent nous vous faisons
vivre effectivement en direct les
coulisses du figaro première étape
l'édition et je suis avec anne huet
directrice adjointe de la rédaction en
charge de l'édition
alors à ce titre est bien expliqué nous
quel est votre rôle et celui de vos
équipes ce soir âme
alors aujourd'hui on est là pour
réaliser le journal pour le mettre en
page pour organiser la soirée pour
pouvoir finir à 21h sachant que les
premiers résultats tombent à 20h ce ne
sont que des estimations
donc il faut tout le reste mais vraiment
tout le reste du journal à part les
élections enfin les pages qui traitent
des élections soient terminés le plus
c'est à dire d'ici cinq dix minutes vous
pouvez le voir là je vais vous expliquer
comment parler du du terme chemin de fer
certains phénomènes faire on voit la
chemin de fer des petits wagons les uns
derrière les autres donc les pages on a
neuf pages donc on a neuf pages sur les
régionales plus une page départementale
qui est ici tout le reste comme vous le
voyez là bon je vous explique sévère
seebach et donc les pages son parti ne
reste plus que celle-ci à partir après
on attend 20 heures et là c'est le rush
on a une heure cela veut dire que vous
dites que ces pages vertes sont partis à
son parti l impression à la presse à
l'imprimerie à l'imprimerie
elles sont calés à l'imprimerie elles
sont pas imprimés encore est-ce qu'il
faut que yelle complet pour pouvoir eux
pour pouvoir organiser le journal et le
et l'imprimé alors vous et vos équipes
est sur le pont évidemment ce soir on
l'a vu à 20 heures qu'est ce qui va se
passer exactement 20 ans je le rappelle
ce sont les publications des premières
estimations de ce second tour des
régionales
on le voit derrière vous il ya nos
équipes qui sont là donc à 20 heures
qu'est ce que vous allez faire en
télétravail et certains ici qu'est ce
qui vous fait à 20 heures alors à vos
acteurs ben on va avoir les premières
estimations donc là je vais vous montrer
sur l'écran on a préparé plusieurs une
je vais pas tout vous détailler mais en
fonction des résultats selon les
résultats en paca selon les résultats
aussi dans les autres régions voilà on a
préparé plusieurs une donc là c'est si
thierry voilà moi son statut et la ville
de demain voilà donc la tyrie main
mariani qui l'emportent en paca la lr
qu'il emporte partout et enfin partout l
air est en tête donc est la même en
définitive bien entendu tous être amené
à bouger
hélas les 5 c'est à dire qu'on en a pas
on n'a pas encore pour l'instant de
résultats on est dans l'expectative donc
on ne sait pas encore ce qu'on va faire
et tout ça sera fait en une heure tout
certain âge et une à une
on imagine que la soirée va se prolonger
jusqu'à tard à quelle heure on pourra
considérer que le journal est
définitivement bouclée alors à une heure
à une heure du matin et sera
définitivement bouclée on a une carte
quand même avec des chiffres quand même
assez précis et entre deux on freine une
édition à 23h et ce sera celle qui sera
dans les kiosques demain matin avec les
autres éditions on en finit une à 21h
qui paraît assez lointain quand même en
france aille le plus loin par rapport à
nos ânes aux imprimeries après 23 heures
on se rapproche un peu de paris donc
c'est finalement les apprennent ile de
france alors que la dernière
l'adversaire inédits sont et distribué
voilà ile-de-france et sud haussier ile
de france est une vache a précisé que
les équipes qui constituent les
personnes qui constituent les
journalistes qui constituent votre
équipe ce sont des secrétaires de
rédaction et des premiers secrétaires de
rédaction tout à fait donc toute
l'équipe est là on a les correcteurs
aussi important ils sont ici ce soir là
pratiquement complet et derrière le
service photo qui permet d'illustrer
bien sûr tout le journal
et la direction artistique que vous ne
voyez pas mais qu est aussi derrière et
qui va beaucoup travailler sur la une
alors pour les gens pour simplifier un
considérablement évidemment les tâches
qui sont relatives aux personnes qui
sont présentes quand vous avez pas de
fautes d'orthographe dans un papier
c'est grâce aux src grâce et les
astucieux trouvé en fonction des angles
choisis pour les papiers et bien ce sont
aussi les secrétaires de rédaction qui
s'en charge et les photos leur taille
est le choix du contenu des photos c'est
aussi les photographes et vous qui avait
le dernier mot
on va mettre la pression beaucoup
rédacteurs ils vont l'avoir beaucoup
jusqu'à 21h la première édition faut
qu'elle soit partie donc je vais faire
un peut détester
bon courage a dit m merci des 50 minutes
ce soir pour vous faire découvrir les
coulisses du figaro je vous rends la
main vincent à tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup charlotte est un grand
salut à hannut est et des formidables
équipes qui met justement une dernière
main sur l'édition papier du figaro vous
allez pouvoir donc découvrir
peu après 21h avec les la première avec
la une et les premières infos les
premières analyses que vous pouvez
suivre également ici en direct on va
continuer à faire ce tour dans la
rédaction du figaro à vous faire
découvrir justement comment on couvre
cette soirée ce qu'il ya derrière les
informations qu'on vous présente on est
en direct donc avec vous je salue encore
vincent qui vient de nous rejoindre
également marcelo et tous et rolland qui
est décidément très actif sur le chat du
figaro merci d'être avec nous ce soir
justement une question peut-être qui est
qui est posée ce commentaire d'abord de
vincent les régions dessiné par monsieur
hollande ne représente plus la
population est ce que c'est l'une des
raisons tous les cas c'est ce super
découpage régional que l'on peut
donner à l'abstention grandissante en
tout cas au phénomène inédit
d'abstention qu'on a connu la semaine
dernière et qu'on connaît encore cette
semaine puisque donc les dernières
projections donnent 33 66 3% pour
l'abstention c'est une question qui
était posée est déjà posée il ya six ans
puisqu'on avait voté pour la première
fois avec ses nouveaux périmètres
mais on constate pas qu'une différence
entre les régions fusionner la nouvelle
aquitaine les lots de france ou
l'occitanie en termes de mobilisation de
participation par rapport à des régions
historiquement très très structurée
comme la bretagne tout le monde a suivi
le même chemin vers une abstention qui a
progressé
les allemands est très endurant bretagne
bretagne paca ile de france qui ne sont
dès qu'ils sont des régions qui n'ont
pas été fusionnées par exemple ou les
mails loire où les pays de loire on a le
on observe le même le même phénomène
d'autres nous pose cette question ça
change quoi de voter c'est quand même
toujours est ce que finalement dans les
premières observations des premières
analyses de l'abstention on
on a cette perception de personnes qui
sont finalement se disent à quoi bon ça
sert à rien d'aller voter
c'est exactement ce qu'on entend le plus
spontanément c'est à dire finalement ça
ne change rien alors ça ne change rien
et lui-même un peu polysémique
ça rappelle qu'on est dans un pays qui
attend que les échéances politiques et
les alternances politiques changent la
vie au quotidien
elle s'est sans doute quelque chose qui
s'est perdu au passage notamment dans
ces scrutins régionaux et départementaux
finalement est-ce que les gens il ya eu
30 départements qui ont basculé en 2000
en 2015 lorsqu'on a voté au mois de mars
est ce que les habitants de ces trente
départements se sont dit ah tiens là il
ya quelque chose d effectivement très
différent de ce que proposait la
majorité intérieur je pense que pas
vraiment dire ça
et puis il ya quelque chose de plus lié
au rapport compliqué qu'on a la vie
politique et à la la compétition
politique avec le sentiment que c'est un
monde à part qui ne nous écoute plus
qu'ils ne nous considèrent plus qui vit
entre soi sa petite compétition pour
s'arracher des postes de pouvoir
mais en fait qu'ils sont plus en prise
avec la vie des français là c'est
effectivement une accusation sans doute
un peu plus grave qui est que ça veut
dire que dans l'esprit d'un certain
nombre d'électeurs la politique ne sert
plus à rien je vous pose la question qui
fâche
ils veulent qu'on a proposé la semaine
comment se fait-il que les instituts de
sondage ce soit autant tromper la
semaine dernière le fait est que on a
une estimation de la participation qui a
été en 200 on est souvent d'ailleurs
très très pessimiste dans les les
sondages on a plutôt tendance à annoncer
des hausses delà de l'abstention sans
qu'ils se produisent et là c'est le
contraire qui s'est produit c'est à dire
qu'on avait annoncé une hausse d'au
moins 10 points elle était de 20 points
donc là on a on a changé de modèle ce
serait un peu aventureux de tirer là
toutes les conclusions
mais de fait on a probablement dans nos
échantillons les gens me mobiliser pour
nous répondre sans doute des gens qui
sont un tout qui peut plus aussi
mobilisé intéressé par par les airs sur
mobilisation entre les
au niveau des réponses qui a pu bien
problématique si on n'avait que faire au
fait qu'on se représenter les électeurs
seraient pas très grave mais il se
trouve que on a donc dans les sondages
des gens qui disent je vais voter et
voilà comment je vais voter qui sont pas
équitablement réparti entre les
différents partis alors que la tante 20
heures pour entrer dans le détail de
l'analyse par parti est toujours dédié
que certains partis parce que leur
sociologie plus d'abstentionnistes
potentiellement ont effectivement
étaient sur-représentés dans les mains
dans les sondages plus pour le rappeler
que donc des résultats connus la semaine
dernière on a découvert rassemblement
national moins fort dans les urnes que
dans les sondages
c'est ce qu'on a vu on a donc un certain
nombre de résultats qui commence à
parvenir dans trois quarts d'heure
maintenant on pourra voir si ses
résultats ses premières estimations qui
nous parviennent correspondent à la une
tendance qui se confirme on vous donnera
tous ses résultats dès 20 heures je vous
propose en attendant ben justement de
voir qui guette ses résultats ses
premières estimations
c'est l'un des poumons ce soir du figaro
c'est le service politique où se trouve
actuellement
charlotte barillon
et oui merci vincent continue de vous
faire vivre en direct les coulisses du
figaro et après être passé par l'édition
nous sommes au service politique de la
rédaction
en présence du rédacteur en chef du
service politique albert et nous bonsoir
albert merci de nous accorder quelques
minutes de votre temps alors pour que
les internautes comprennent bien comment
vous fonctionnez et comment fonctionne
une rédaction
quel est votre rôle quelle est votre
mission avouée celle de vos équipes au
service politique ce soir l'idée c'est
de toujours pareil de suivre l'actualité
politique la hauteur aujourd'hui
sélection président d'élections
régionales et départementales pour les
oublier celle là et bah il faut donner
le plus être le plus proche possible des
résultats les gens veulent des résultats
ce soir c'est un deuxième tour avec un
peu de suspens notamment dans une région
du sud
donc la région paca je le reconnais il
faut être le plus proche de ça donc nous
on a des estimations on a en fait
remonter des faits remonter des
informations qu'on a qu'on ne peut pas
diffusés avant 20h est donc le l'idée
c'est de ces de finaliser et de d'être
le plus proche possible de la réalité
donc nous on a un avantage c'est d'avoir
des informations on a un inconvénient
c'est que notre on a une édition qui
boucle à 21h une fois que c'est parti
c'est parti nous avec nos lecteurs
demain matin ils auront l'édition contre
boucle à 21h dont il faut être
il faut être le le plus près de la
réalité de la réalité on passe il faut
pas se planter comme on dit donc il faut
absolument donner des chiffres qui sont
qui soit juste s'ils ne sont pas on le
dit on ne va pas mentir à nos lecteurs
puisque demain matin ce qui nous lirons
aurons les résultats
donc on a fait un jeu un peu à peu
particulier où il faut il faut anticiper
mais pas trop alors je le disais vous
êtes rédacteur en chef du service
politique à combien de journalistes ce
soir qui sont sur le pont pour
approvisionner la home du figaro.fr et
puis aussi le print demain matin on
dirait il y avait une quinzaine de
journalistes qui sont dans le service
plus des gens qui sont nos
correspondants en province en a
quelques-uns et qui nous alimente sur
des régions qu'on ne peut pas connaître
aussi bien que et qu'ils sont sur place
donc c'est du reportage c'est s'aider
c'est des ambiances c'est tout ça qui
nous intéresse nous redoux ce qu'on veut
donner à nos lecteurs la possibilité de
connaître plus précisément plus finement
non seulement les résultats mais aussi
des ambiances et donner quelque chose
des données a expliqué il faut il faut
être pédagogue et pédagogue et en même
temps donner quelque chose d'intéressant
à lire et à voir et à comprendre
nous notre rôle de journaliste mais ça
c'est vrai pour tous les gens lisent du
monde entier c2c d'expliquer de faire
comprendre que c'est notre rôle
expliquer et faire comprendre c'est ce
qu'ont fait effectivement en ce moment
en vous montrant aussi les coulisses du
fonctionnement du figaro albert zeh nous
certains papiers sont d'ores et déjà
publiées ils l'ont été depuis ce matin
sur lefigaro.fr en rapport avec ce
scrutin du deuxième tour d'autres sont
écrits après 20 heures
comment est choisi le papier qui sera
publié en home celui qui sera relégué en
seconde position quand vous faites le
choix entre ce qui a déjà été fait ce
qui va être fait et ce qui est en train
d'être fait c'est toujours d'actualité
qui prit donc le plus chaud seul le
papier qui va être le plus le plus
intelligent le plus intéressant le plus
proche là aussi de l'actualité le plus
le plus qui donnera le résultat le plus
cher et le plus sûr ça c'est le sas skis
et c'est ce qui nous motive le plus donc
après et maintenant bien entendu pour
écrire autant de papillons d'être on a
douze pages qui paraîtra demain il faut
préparer en avance et en amont
les pages donc on a commencé à écrire
mais sans donner de résultat j'ai toute
une machine de derrière très subtiles
qui comme un jeu d'échecs mon avance les
pions au fur et à mesure de l'évolution
jean finalisera tout ça entre 20h30 et
21h vendu beaucoup on entend le
téléphone qui sonne je vais vous libérer
albert et nous juste avant qu'on se
quitte
quelle est votre priorité là à l'instant
où on se parle quand je vais vous
laisser vous allez faire quoi c'est de
vérifier les chiffres c'est ça le
problème
nous notre d'autres d'autres noteront
une autre notre objectif c'est d'être le
plus près du jeu la véracité de l'impôt
merci beaucoup à elle versé nous pour
cette ont accordé en direct et sur
figaro live il vous rend la main vincent
roux à tout à l'heure
merci charlotte et mercy à l'excellent
albert zeh nous pour c'est pour ces
précisions donc vous voyez comme
fiabilité vous pouvez accorder quel
sérieux en tous les cas il y a à
vérifier ces chiffres c'est l'obsession
qui a non seulement au service politique
mais également au figaro ici même
également je salue également les abonnés
à la sélection figaro live la newsletter
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous être fidèles régulièrement merci
beaucoup d'être abonné à cette
newsletter ou grâce à laquelle vous
pouvez vient nous voir en direct ce soir
merci donc également à aux internautes
qui qui nous rejoignent
justement et qui nous disent comme
marcelo le fait qu'on sort d'une année
léthargique de statu quo ne me permet
pas de déterminer quels sont les bons
candidats est ce que il y avait un autre
internaute
rolland qui nous disait dans le doute
abstiens toi est-ce que ce doute est ce
que cette méconnaissance peut être des
enjeux cette méconnaissance des
candidats cet éloignement ne fait même
pas se sentir concernés par cette
élection a joué et joue encore un rôle
dans cette abstention massive emmanuel
et plusieurs choses qui je pense ont
joué un rôle dans cette abstention
massive à la c'est bien d'avoir fait
allusion à cette année léthargique parce
qu'il ya aussi cette question qui se
pose finalement quand est ce qu'on a vu
une hausse de 20 points de l'abstention
lors d'élections pour lesquelles on se
sentait concerné c'est l'année dernière
aux municipales ou
on est passé en a franchi les 50 %
d'abstention ce qui était absolument
inouïe on était effectivement dans un
contexte très particulier qui était le
contexte le contexte pandémique
il se trouve que il ya deux choses qui
doivent nous inciter à penser que ce
n'est pas ça explique l'abstention cette
année d'une part qu' on n'est pas les
seuls à avoir connu l'épidémie de kobe
de 19 et que dans bien d'autres pays on
a voté cette année l'an dernier avec un
taux de participation quasiment normaux
y compris pour des élections régionales
à madrid en italie en allemagne et par
ailleurs en mesure chaque mois pour le
figaro magazine
on va remettre quand un public one punk
l'intérêt pour la politique est intérêt
pour la politique est effectivement
tombé à des planchers
l'an dernier au moment des municipales
autour de 30% très très bas retrouvent
des niveaux normaux pas flamboyant mais
normaux avec à peu près la moitié des
gens qui disent s'intéresser à la
politique
ce qui veut dire que les gens nous
disent aujourd'hui si la politique
m'intéresse mais ce que vous nous donner
à voir là à travers ces élections
la compétition entre les parties ça ça
nous intéresse pas je pense que c'est en
fait deux choses qui sont très interrogé
par ses 65 points 5 % d'abstention d'une
part la compréhension du modèle de la
décentralisation à la française des
enjeux qu'il ya autour des départements
et des régions en fait ça c'est pas du
tout approprié
on a on s'est rendu compte dans une
enquête il ya à peine un mois que la
moitié des gens ne connaissaient pas
l'étiquette politique d'aidé de leur
président de région
du coup c'est l'autre leçon principale
qu'il faut en tirer jusqu'à présent on
vivait pas trop mal avec cette fois
artistique sur la connaissance des
compétences des régions et départements
mais comme nous posez des questions
politiques sur ce qu'on va voter pour
soutenir le gouvernement favoriser
l'opposition à votre sanction qu'on
n'était pas indifférent qui allait
gagner l'élection
on aimerait quand même voté aujourd'hui
en fait on est devenu un peu indifférent
à cette compétition entre les partis
politiques une question de millénium est
ce que les français d'origine
immigré première deuxième troisième
génération votre plus que les autres non
ça c'est alors il faut être assez
prudent sur les statistiques dont on
peut disposer sur ces questions là
puisque priori sur les listes
électorales tout le monde est français
au même rapport aux 10 degrés simplement
on a vu dans les banlieues où il ya une
forte proportion de populations
étrangères donc par déduction aussi le
genre de population proportion de
populations d'origine étrangère et
l'abstention grimper énormément mais à
toutes les élections c'est à dire qu'il
ya une très forte participation en 2007
quand il s'agissait d' arbitrer entre
ségolène royal et nicolas sarkozy et en
2012 c'est beaucoup moins fort et il
n'est d'ailleurs une grande partie des
déconvenues de la gauche en banlieue
parisienne notamment vient du fait de
l'abstention devenu très massives dans
un certain nombre de ses anciens
bastions
et dans ces secteurs qui sont prisés
notamment par par la gauche et en
particulier depuis la fameuse note de
terra nova on y reviendra peut-être
qu'on va justement retrouver un
spécialiste des chiffres et de l'analyse
de ces chiffres au figaro c'est
l'analyste par excellence le
commentateur chaque jour du contrepoint
guillaume tabard qui est avec charlotte
bahreïn
mais bon on est on est à la bonne heure
eh bien oui merci vincent on continue à
vous faire découvrir les coulisses du
figaro vous en voyez même les coulisses
au delà de l'entreprise d'antenne
puisque vous venez de vous entendre on
off je suis désormais dans le bios de
guillaume tabard éditorialiste politique
au figaro on vous voyait en train de
travailler
vous avez d'ores et déjà choisi l'angle
de votre contrepoint que vous allez
faire publier dans le journal et oui
l'angle principal de mon contrepoint
sera de tirer les leçons de ce scrutin
de ce second tour des régionales
pour emmanuel macron et sur la manière
dont il va orienter maintenant là ce qui
va être la dernière étape de son
quinquennat puisqu'on est maintenant à
dix mois de la prochaine présidentielle
et surtout que ces régionales était la
dernière élection avant la
présidentielle on sait maintenant qu
emmanuel macron doit mettre en place son
dispositif à la fois politique peut être
humain est surtout politique sert que
quelques ailes réforme quelle ligne il
va adopter pour pour cette dernière
étape de son quinquennat
dans quelle mesure les premières
estimations les résultats qui vont
arriver au cours de cette soirée de ce
second tour des régionales interfèrent
si je puis dire dans la rédaction de
votre contrepoint c'est sûr que
connaître ou anticipés ou deviner les
résultats de ce soir sont importants
avant d'écrire parce que c'est sûr que
la conséquence sont pas les mêmes 6 s'il
y avait une victoire du rassemblement
national en paca ou s'il n'y en a pas
que la gauche l'emportent dans certaines
régions ou non que telle ou telle
sortants de droite fasse un score
particulièrement spectaculaires ou non
voilà tous tout ça sont les ingrédients
qui peuvent influer en tout cas dictée
un petit peu le la tonalité du du
commentaire vous pourriez décider
finalement de changer du tout au tout et
de basculer sur un autre angle dans les
minutes ou l'heure qui suit et si oui
jusqu'à quel point jusqu'à quelle heure
vous avez la possibilité de le faire en
fonction de l'heure du bouclage
le journaliste fait de manière évolutive
d'abord sur le sur le sur le site il se
fait en temps réel pour l'édition prime
5 amont l'appel
c'est sûr qu'il faudra que dans que l'on
envoie nos papiers vers 20h15 20h30 dire
que les résultats réels à peine que nous
en tout cas les estimations sciemment
fiables sur les régions à peine connu
donc le temps de réaction sera très
court bien sûr ensuite le journal
rafraîchissez édition a offert mesure où
l'imprimerie tourne bien on peut
réactualiser les papiers jusqu'à une
certaine heure de de la soirée de
changer votre angle du tout au tout
citons le propre pays
il faut être capable de s'adapter si
vraiment des surprises bombay d'où
l'importance de savoir s'il ya ou non
des surprises colossal ce soir alors
nous parlons qu'est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire alors bien sûr maintenant
on a le droit de dépasser la limite
limite
disons simplement que je peux vous dire
que je ne pense pas avoir beaucoup à
réécrire
dans la soirée je pense que les éléments
que l'on a permettent d'aider cette
première édition d'être dans la tonalité
globale de ces élections à vous parler
de surprise guillaume tabard est ce que
on peut considérer qu'il ya un certain
suspense dans ce scrutin et si oui
est-ce que vous abordez cette soirée et
cette échéance avec une certaine
excitation ou un certain intérêt plus
particulier que d'habitude la soirée
électorale où il ya toujours un côté un
peu excitant je reprends votre terre
mais gaye il ya de ça parce que c'est
sûr que d'abord on est plus sur des
sondages on est vraiment sur le vote
lui-même donc c'est le choix les
français qui comptait y accueillir que
celui là qui compte parce que c'est vrai
que il ya ce petit moment d'adresser des
dom d'adrénaline créé par ce laps de
temps très court entre la connaissance
des résultats et le moment où elle peut
écrire donc c'est vrai qu'on est dans
une séquence très très intenses
voilà qui fait partie de la balle et je
pense d des plaisirs du métier et c'est
vrai que en règle générale et notamment
le figaro les soirées électorales c'est
toujours des moments à la fois intense
et donc sympathique
merci beaucoup de minutes passées avec
vous vincent ben on se retrouve encore
dans quelques minutes je serai cette
fois ci aux figues dattes ah ben oui
peut-être que ça ne parle pas pour
certains d'entre vous eh ben on va vous
expliquer en quoi consiste la data au
figaro a tout de suite et vous avez
raison c'est très important la data au
figaro et on est très contents de vous
faire découvrir justement tous
travaillent tous services que vous
pouvez déjà voir et en particulier sur
le site avec tous les résultats tous les
chiffres
on va y revenir c'est passionnant et
c'est très intéressant et on est très
heureux de vous faire partager ça on est
très heureux d'accueillir également sur
notre plateau l'excellent yves thréard
bonsoir bonsoir comment ça va vincent
yves on a commenté commencé à commenter
avec
emmanuel rivière le la seul le seul
chiffre qu'on peut commenter ce soir là
seule projection qu'on peut commenter
c'est le la très léger regain de
participation une abstention qui serait
aux alentours de don de 65 3%
comment vous analyser ça est ce que
c'est pour vous et si le nesc ou bien
est ce que ça veut ça veut c'est c'est
le signe comme le disait tout à l'heure
et manuel d'un sursaut coûté la mesure
alors la tension est très forte la
semaine dernière elle craint surtout
elle est très très forte cette semaine
encore et le sursaut je suis désolé
pardon emmanuel saez facilement été
utilisé il ya pas eu de sursaut du
toucan gilets fouettent sursaut alors
faut voir région par région
là où il y avait peut-être bas par
exemple là où il y avait un duel qui
était claire et nette entre le
rassemblement national et la majorité et
les républicains il ya eu davantage de
je crois de participation en pack pas
cap
il ya eu trois ou quatre points de plus
si mes informations sont bonnes mais bon
je vois pas pourquoi ça pouvait changer
d'une semaine à l'autre au contraire
il y avait le tour de france en plus
donc ça faisait une raison non plus pour
peut-être ne pas aller voter dans trêve
de plaisanterie le mal est profond le
mal et est énorme et je vois parents
d'une semaine comment il aurait pu être
résolu le mal pour moi il vient
principalement du fait que les français
et considère cette élection comme tout à
fait lisible
ils ne comprennent pas à quoi elle sert
nous en france on est un pays
extrêmement centralisé en plus donc on a
une tentation centralisatrice y compris
intellectuelle qui est très forte avec
des élections déterminantes sélection de
l'année prochaine l'élection
présidentielle même l'élection
législative aujourd'hui a pris un coup
dans l'air et on l'a vu la dernière
édition puisque saint quentin un
électeur sur deux ne s'étaient pas
déplacés aux élections législatives qui
sont pourtant là à peu près
incompréhensible
donc je vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui on
aurait eu une meilleure participation me
semble-t-il
il faut évidemment réfléchir aux
nouveaux modes de participation avec le
vote la distance le vote numérique tout
ça mais c'est pas ça qui va qui va
résoudre le problème le problème c'est
dans la défiance de plus en plus vives
qui existe entre les personnels
politiques au plus tôt les électeurs et
personnel politique et c'est ça qu'il
faut résoudre le résoudre ça se fait pas
en un jour ça c'est pas en une semaine
c'est de la responsabilité des hommes et
des femmes politiques c'est aussi de la
responsabilité des citoyens des citoyens
qui bat
souvent en france sont geignard
colérique sont rarement le genre
d'acteur mais si on n'est pas content
bas il faut aller voter pour justement
faire en sorte que ça change et les
gaulois réfractaires c'est une
expression qui m'ont pas tout à fait
adapté pays
c'est donc sur l'expression donc je la
retiens de lustrer ah bon c'est une
citation mais elle n'a pas été déposé
pour l'instant nous allons avoir donc
tous les résultats dans quelques dans un
petit peu moins d'une demi heure
maintenant les résultats au niveau
national par formation par les
politiques nous allons avoir les
premiers résultats dans un certain
nombre de régions et nous allons avoir
donc les résultats que nous donne l'ifop
fiducial mais il ya tout le reste c'est
tout un travail de traitement de données
et je vous propose de découvrir donc ce
qui les met à jour ses seins des travail
à des travaux passionnants un des plus
du figaro et charlotte marion est
justement là où ça se passe
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour dans la newsroom
du figaro au coeur de cette rédaction je
vous avais dit qu'on allait parler de
data du fiqh data est pour beaucoup
d'entre vous ça ne veut pas dire grand
chose et bien on est là pour vous les
expliquer puisque nous sommes en direct
avec le rédacteur en chef du fiqh data
justement stéphane saunier
bonjour stéphane bonjour merci nous
accorder quelques secondes à dans ce
moment à quelques minutes les premières
estimations qui devront arriver vers un
vers 20 heures alors éclairé nous sur la
data et plus particulièrement sur une
figue data c'est quoi alors le fica ça
c'est très simple en fin de compte c'est
une cellule de datajournalisme alors le
data gens lisent ce n'est pas forcément
un mot qui parle non plus au plus grand
nombre
donc pour faire très simple l'objectif
pour nous ça va être de collecter et
d'analyser de la donner en vue de faire
des sujets éditoriaux donc des sujets en
fin de compte au même titre qu'une
enquête où les choses comme ça on va
aller nous enquêté auprès de la date a
donc directement au sein des chiffres et
alors vous en tant que rédacteur en chef
de file data comment vous travaillez
quel est votre rôle votre mission ce
soir dans ce dispositif et vos équipes
que font-elles autour de vous alors gros
le plus spécifiquement à moi ça va être
d'organiser éditorialement justement la
recherche des données et la collecte en
fin de compte donc trouver les
thématiques qui vont nous permettre
d'aller traiter l'actualité parce que la
difficulté pour nous ça va être d'aller
chercher les données en amont c'est à
dire qu'on va pas forcément être capable
sur l'instant t de sortir une donnée
puisqu'on va être nécessairement obligé
d'aller les chercher l'analyse et le
traité donc en fin de compte on va être
sur un temps un peu plus long mais on va
essayer de prévoir ce temps on va
essayer d'être malgré tout au rendez
vous de l'actualité et pour être au
rendez vous de l'actualité
bah mon rôle à moi ça va être de penser
en amont quelles peuvent être les sujets
d'actualité qui vont être importants et
que sur lequel fit date a pu intervenir
on est au coeur de votre service allo
pizza il ya combien de journalistes ce
soir qui travaillent sur ce dispositif
spécial pour les régionales alors ce
soir on a six personnes donc dans
l'équipe on a des profils qui sont très
différents les uns des autres c'est ça
qui est très intéressant on va avoir à
la fois des gens qui travaillent sur
l'infographie donc le visuel la
restitution en fin de compte des données
je commence par l'infographie en fin de
compte c'est la dernière étape c'est la
restitution et si je remonte le temps on
va avoir à la fois des data journalisme
donc des personnes qui sont en charge de
chercher des données les traiter en
amont pour avoir des sujets et on va
avoir entre les deux en fin de compte
des développeurs donc des profils qui
sont un peu hybride à la fois
journaliste est à la fois développeur
qui vont eux travaillé vraiment
techniquement le moteur typiquement pour
une action comme ce soir
on va avoir besoin en amont de se
connecter aux données du ministère pour
pouvoir les restituer une fille née sur
le site et sur le quotidien le lendemain
alors si on rentre dans le vif du sujet
qu'elle quel contenu précisément vous
avez choisi de mettre en avant ce soir
ou que vous allez mettre en avant ce
soir
est ce que ce sont des cartes et ce sont
des graphes et si oui qu'est ce qu'ils
vont représenter
ces éléments pour les lecteurs alors ça
va être un peu tout ça donc
effectivement ce soir la grande
nouveauté pour nous au figaro c'est
qu'on présente en fin de compte les
résultats en temps réel directement sur
la home du figaro donc pour vous
internautes plus besoin de rafraîchir sa
page plus besoin d'aller chercher
l'information vraiment on a décidé cette
fois de vous la portez directement sur
la home de façon la plus simple et la
plus directe possible donc ça va être
vous allez voir à partir de 20 heures ou
un petit peu après dès que le ministère
nous aura transmis les données des
cartes non des cartes de résultats des
parisiens des cartes de haut avec avec
les couleurs selon les partis les
nuances et les grandes nuances qu'on a
qu'on a aggloméré
on va avoir les résultats sur les
départementales on va avoir les
évidemment on a depuis midi et depuis 17
heures et on aura à 20 heures la
participation est l'abstention et vous
allez avoir également comme au premier
tour un moteur de recherche qui vous
permettra d'avoir directement les
résultats pour votre commune alors à 20
heures les premières estimations vont
tomber
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
précisément au moment où ces estimations
tombent
voilà c'est la course pour nous c'est la
course parce qu'on va en aussi en fait
entre deux choses on oscille entre les
les estimations des sondeurs qui sont au
final jusqu'à 20h les seules
informations dont on va disposer et on
va passer entre 20h20 heure 5 on sait
pas trop justement selon la réactivité
du ministère on va passer sur des
données partielles donc les premiers
résultats qui commence à émerger qui
sont des résultats sortis vraiment des
urnes
une fois que ça a été vraiment
dépouillés merci beaucoup stéphane
ferrier de nous avoir accordé quelques
minutes de votre temps je rappelle vous
êtes rédacteur en chef du fiqh data dans
quelques minutes nous continuerons à
poursuivre cette découverte cette visite
des coulisses du figaro nous serons en
direct avec la directrice des rédactions
du figaro.fr le rang et charette a tout
de suite
merci beaucoup dans un peu moins de 20
minutes maintenant on va connaître donc
la physionomie ces résultats dont
parlait à l'instant
stéphane saunier que vous allez pouvoir
voir en direct sur le site du figaro et
vous allez pouvoir les vivre avec nous
merci beaucoup
d'être d'être avec nous il ya une
question que pose roland à l'instant
qu'il dit est ce qu'on risque pas une
fracture état région la question c'est
même est ce qu'on n'a pas une phrase
l'expression d'une fracture entre l'état
et le reste des territoires et de la pop
et de la population
non je crois pas si cette fracture
existent elles existent depuis longtemps
b faut peut-être pas non plus trop là
souligné comme ça a été fait par
certains écrivains intellectuels
sociologues avec une rupture entre la
province et paris
les territoires et les grandes
métropoles penser à christophe guilluy
par exemple oui ça existe évidemment que
ça existe ça a toujours existé ne faut
peut-être pas non plus aussi à force
d'en parler de la souligneront la
caricature cette fracture presque je
dirais les fractures sont multiples dans
notre pays ne sont pas uniquement
territoriales elles sont aussi sociale
elles sont aussi culturelles elles sont
de menthe de maths ordre et c'est pas
les régionales qui book qui vous feront
les régler ses factures et person nes
comptait d'ailleurs sur les régionales
pour que ce soit le cas donc il faut au
contraire je pense que le futur
quinquennat aura beaucoup de travail et
de pain sur la planche
parce que finalement on s'aperçoit que
ce quinquennat qui vient de se dérouler
il a été marqué par trois événements
importants enfin deux événements
importants qui a été la crise des gilet
jaune de la crise sanitaire il ya eu
deux crises majeures plus si on y ajoute
la crise terroristes islamiques et bien
qui a empêché finalement ce cas nature
se dérouler de façon normale et avec des
réformes qui étaient prévus au programme
du président de la république
ce qui est frappant par rapport à ça on
voit bien hiatus ce soir comme la
semaine dernière entre cette espèce
d'adhésion de principe à l'échelon
territorial
proximité avec cette hiérarchie qu'on
voit tous les ans dans le baromètre
notamment du cevipof sur la confiance
politique où on accorde une grande
confiance aux élus municipaux et une
assez grande confiance aux élus
départementaux et régionaux
curieusement d'ailleurs toujours au même
niveau toujours dans le même paquet dont
il est à la fois une forme d'attachement
un peu théorique mais une grande
difficulté à s'approprier ces échelons
territoriaux dans leurs compétences leur
mode de fonctionnement dans leur réalité
et compris je le rappelais tout à
l'heure dans leur existence politique
puisque on ignore en fait l'étiquette
politique de leur président donc c'est
un peu compliqué de se dire qu'on va
voter à des élections pour décider de
quelque chose dont on ignorait quel
était l'état l'état antérieur et c'est
ça qui est aussi interrogé par ce taux
de l'abstention on a deux sujets en fait
on à ce sujet des électeurs qui sont pas
croire que les gens qui sont abstenus la
semaine dernière à troyes sont forcément
des gens malheureux ou en colère je vous
coupe d'ailleurs une nouvelle projection
qui vient d'être envoyée par ifop
fiducial sur l'abstention qui serait
maintenant de 66% 66% alors on se
rapproche donc c'est encore moins un
sursaut en fait ce qui se passe -
revient voir regard non mais ce qui se
passe c'est que la petite france qu'à
voter à fait comme d'habitude aux
régionales alors un peu plus voter au
second tour qu'au premier tour
la dernière édition de 2015 étant
l'exception
on avait beaucoup plus voter au second
tour qu'au premier tour c'est la france
qui vote qu'elle choisit de ne pas voter
mais en conscience parce que c'est aussi
ça que nous dit ce taux quasiment
reproduit c'est qu'on assume en fait
c'était pas juste alors on s'excuse on
n'a pas fait attention on n'a pas fait
exprès je vous promets une dimanche
prochain on sera là c'est totalement
assumée c'est une manière de dire non
décidément ça ne nous concerne pas est
ce que je commençais à dire se sont pas
forcément des gens désespérés en colère
et tout un tas de gens qui sont
d'ailleurs la france en comparaison avec
ses voisins est beaucoup plus désespéré
de sa politique de sa situation les gens
individuellement quand on me pose la
question est-ce que c'est l'avis de
mener les perspectifs autre emploi les
revenus doute foyer la france se situe
dans la bonne moyenne européenne dans
son rapport aux partis politiques au
vote
très en retard dans un peu moins d'un
quart d'heure maintenant on saura qui
l'emportent en paca en nouvelles
aquitaine si xavier bertrand transforme
l'essai dans les hauts de france
bref toutes les tendances toutes les
infos à découvrir sur le web en vidéo à
vivre avec nous et je voulais c'est bien
justement avec une des chefs d'orchestre
de cette opération laurence de charette
qui est à la fois la directrice de
figaro lag et du figaro.fr avec laquelle
se trouve actuellement charlotte
barillon d'une brouille
et oui merci versa on continue à vous
montrez vous faire découvrir les
coulisses du figaro et les coulisses du
figaro.fr c'est aussi avec la directrice
de la rédaction du figaro.fr d'où
sortent avec laurence de charette je
vous l'avais dit bonsoir laurence les
minutes avancent les minutes avancent on
est à quelques minutes de la publication
des premières estimations on imagine
qu'à mesure que cette échéance approche
et bien les internautes sont de plus en
plus nombreux à se connecter au site du
figaro.fr
dans quelle mesure vous les suivez ses
audiences et comment fonctionne-t-elle
d'ailleurs sur le site nos jours du
scrutin
alors bien sûr on les suit et une
abstention importante n'empêche pas du
tout une belle audience sur le site du
figaro.fr la semaine dernière il y avait
à peu près il y avait plusieurs millions
de personnes je crois que je pas sûr que
je puisse dire tout aussi vu plusieurs
millions personnes quelle vision suivent
assidûment toute cette soirée se sont
connectés sur le site du figaro qui se
sont connectés et qui sont restés très
tard dans la soirée on sait d'expérience
que ce soir et resteront au delà de
minuit et nous évidemment derrière
l'écran on y sera également
et puis on a vu l'a déjà dans la journée
que aux alentours de 18 heures la
machine s'était mis à chauffer que sur
le live on a vu affluer les lecteurs les
internautes figaro qui se sont branchés
sur ce format qui permet de suivre la
soirée on continue et puis aussi le fils
robin giguère au point fr c'est un site
de référence et on est également très
suivie depuis l'étranger ce soir je
regardais juste avant de vous recevoir
nos amis du royaume uni de belgique de
suisse notamment font l'espagne m soit
signifierait ctso l'humain alors on a vu
avec albert et nos rédacteurs en chef du
service politique tout à l'heure que le
figaro avait une offre qui était quitté
d'être la plus complète la plus précise
la plus sérieuse possible évidemment ça
fait partie de notre adn est de travail
de journaliste qu'elle est là le contenu
éditorial les objectifs éditoriaux du
figaro
un soir de ce scrutin comme celui ci
alors notre objectif c'est tout le temps
mais évidemment particulièrement ce soir
pour une soirée comme celle-là c'est
toujours d'être dans l'hyper réactivité
et la profondeur en même temps c'est
toujours de jouer ses deux jambes qui
sont l'information en continu et
l'analyse
ce flou l'éclairer d'une intelligence
maximum et tout en étant toujours dans
cette réactivité qui est aujourd'hui
absolument indispensable à nos lecteurs
et tout ça évidemment ça s'improvise pas
évidemment c'est évidemment c'est le
fruit de l expertise de nous votre
expertise de la partie de l'ensemble des
journalistes de la rédaction et des
rédactions mais c'est aussi quelque
chose qui se prépare et qui s'anticipe
en amont c'est quelque chose avec elle
on a travaillé la semaine dernière on y
travaille depuis ce matin et qui tout au
long de la soirée demande une
coordination intense et ici voilà autour
des différentes options à chacun sait ce
qu'il a à faire pour que se déroulait
minutes et se passe comme on l'a
souhaité désirer je parlais de votre
expertise en particulier parce que vous
êtes le chef d'orchestre de cette
couverture on va dire sur lepoint fr
comment vous travaillez concrètement là
ce soir on voit derrière nous il y à une
partie des journalistes de la rédaction
qui travaille en ce moment et je vois la
pendule on est à un quart d'heure
maintenant des premières estimations
comment on travaille alors c'est ce
quart d'heure qui explique ici une salle
très particulière il ya beaucoup de
monde mais il n'y a pas de bruit c'est
un signe de concentration intense et
dans le quart d'heure c'est encore plus
perceptible à leur bas autour derrière
moi vous voyez notamment la table la
table centrale ça c'est un peu la table
vous voyez où il ya le plus de monde
là c'est vraiment là tous passé la
cabine de pilotage ce soir c'est
frédéric picard qui est le chef
d'orchestre de l'ensemble demain matin à
l'aube arrivera mario joseph qui
reprendra tout ça est à leurs côtés à
chaque fois ses différents métiers qui
sont absolument indispensables pour que
la soirée se passe de la meilleure des
façons possibles donc aller alors vous
excuserez nos jargon amaya les flashs
heures qui vont s'attacher tout au long
de la soirée a donné les résultats à
travers les régions dans les différentes
régions dès qu'ils arrivent voilà il ya
les live earth qui remplissent ce live
que justement l'ensemble des internautes
suivent beaucoup depuis 18 heures
allez hop et jazz à l'hébergeur c'est
encore autre chose c'est ce sont des
personnes qui tiennent la home du figaro
et qui doivent en temps réel lui assurer
la meilleure hiérarchisation de
l'information
et puis allez réseau maïté qui va
s'occuper justement du suivi de
l'audience parce que l'ensemble de ces
articles de ces vidéos de ses analyses
de ces data etc
comment on les pense excellente on veut
absolument qu'elle soit vue par le
maximum de gens donc on y travaille tout
au long de la soirée et puis à l'édition
on est allé voir tout à l'heure avec
annuel voilà mais l'édition web
également silvert et samuel et bien
pour lepoint fr évidemment qu'ils vont
s'attacher tout au long de la soirée
c'est un métier extrêmement précieux qui
vont s'attacher à mettre en page
l'ensemble de ces articles et d'offrir
un écrin tout particulier pour nos
abonnés et c'est grâce à eux que vous
pourrez dès 22h15 à peu près peut-être
qu'on aura trois milles de retard mais
pas beaucoup plus lire le pdf sur le
site du figaro merci beaucoup laurence
de charette pour ces quelques minutes
passées ensemble je crois vous avez des
pushs à faire partir là la bouche heures
en vidéo absolument il derrière moi et
je peux vous dire qu'ils sont sur les
starting blocks
mais là c'est encore le réseau sur la
lys sur cet entretien bonne soirée je
vous rend l'antenne vincent roux et je
vous dis à tout à l'heure pour dans une
trentaine de minutes faire un petit
point faut tous ensemble
à tout à l'heure charlotte alors il ya
des pushers je pense pas que les
putschistes dans tous les cas on veut on
verra ça pour l'instant on va suivre
maintenant dans une parce qu'on a dans
une 10 dans moins de dix minutes
maintenant
les premiers résultats les enjeux parti
par parti arrivé en tête lors du premier
tour c'est les républicains et leurs
alliés pour eux
l'enjeu est surtout la victoire c'est de
remporter plus de régions les
républicains ils ont vécu deux
expériences électorales très contrastées
pendant ce quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
première aux européennes une expérience
malheureuse avec la contre-performance
de monsieur bellamy en dessous de 10% et
ensuite les élections municipales pas
une divine surprise parce qu'on s'y
attendait mais qui cette manière
rétablissait avec dans le sillage leurs
conséquences des élections sénatoriales
les républicains comme le premier parti
d'opposition institutionnellement que ce
soit l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs
comme au sénat donc là on a à nouveau
une élection locale et l'enjeu c'est
évidemment de ré apparaître comme le
champion des élections locales
derrière lequel il y aura tout de suite
l'autre ce qui reste la complexité pour
la république ans aujourd'hui qui est
une question de leadership et entre les
différentes figures de ces régionales
qui aura d'une certaine manière trouver
la meilleure martingale ou prétendre à
la voir faire yves pour vous les
républicains l'enjeu pour les
républicains c'était de savoir
il est il et c'était une répétition
générale avant l'année prochaine
en plus maintenant la compétition va
commencer on voit bien que madame
pécresse monsieur wauquiez monsieur
bertrand s'il ya une ce soir les trois
bas ils vont se lancer dans la bagarre
pour la présidentielle ce qu'on sait
c'est je confirme ce que dit et le
manuel c'est que de toute manière on le
savait c'est le parti le plus implanté
de france le républicain faut pas
oublier ça a permis de rappeler aux
français que c'est le parti des
républicains qui détient la majorité au
sénat qui détient le plus grand groupe
d'opposition l'assemblée nationale à
quelque 100 députés qui a en main la
plupart des grandes villes des régions
des départements
donc les républicains ils ont un seul
problème c'est celui de l'incarnation
nationale et peut-être que ces
régionales vont justement lui servir on
va là on va le voir
est ce que ces régionales vont lui
servir à bah justement à faire émerger
cette incarnation nationale ou au
contraire est-ce que ça va encore
démultiplié les bagarres les
annie interne
au parti et à la droite parce qu'il faut
le dire d'un pécresse et monsieur
bertrand ne sont plus à l'intérieur des
républicains l'enjeu pour le pour le
rassemblement national
c'est bien sûr de gagner une région
ce soir si ça n'est pas le cas qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est symboliquement très
très important parce que ça avait été
déjà important 2015 le fait de ne pas
gagner de région avait pesé sur
finalement cette dynamique qui incite
les électeurs du rassemblement national
à revenir et à se mobiliser en fait il
ya dans tout vote de protestation un peu
le même phénomène
on va voter on se rend compte que ça a
un effet les soirs d'élection et parce
que ça fait ça bouscule le système ça
bouscule les partis établis maintenant
font que ça dépasse et donc il ya cette
thématique dur pour le rassemblement
national sempiternel du plafond de verre
qui est très caractéristique d'un parti
d'extrême droite qui ne fait pas
d'alliance il n'a pas beaucoup en europe
comme cela il y en a d'autres à l'afd
pour l'instant et un ou deux autres et
donc il ya cette question-là arriver
enfin décrocher une table un échelon
plus significatif que celui des
municipales pour le parti socialiste on
a vu que finalement le parti socialiste
et ses alliés résister plutôt pas mal au
premier tour il ya eu des alliances
cette fois ci on imagine que l'enjeu
c'est à la fois de garder les régions
qu'ils dirigent
et peut-être d'en gagner une ou deux ce
soir oui bah pour tous tous les partis
toutes les formations politiques qu'il
s'agit de gagner ça c'est évident on
verra déjà le parti socialiste dont on
disait que c'était un cadavre à la
renverse ya pas très longtemps on
s'aperçoit quand même que il arrive à se
maintenir dans les élections locales de
façon tout à fait décente un les
municipales n'ont pas été un naufrage
pour lui pareil pour au premier tour de
ces élections régionales
là la compétition à gauche elle est à
gauche entre le parti socialiste et les
écologistes
les écologistes ont vent poupe ils l'ont
eu aux européennes ils l'ont eu d'une
certaine façon aux municipales
puisqu'ils ont remporté pas mal de
grandes villes c'est une question de
leadership là entre voilà et puis de
savoir aussi comment la france a soumis
se comportent et on sait qu'elle n'est
pas très forte sur le plan de son
implantation territoriale n'est pas très
très bonne ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que l'union ne fait pas la force
soit là s'émeut on l'a vu dans les hauts
de france
il y avait une liste d'union qui
réunissait toutes les formations de
gauche de n'est pas du parti radical de
gauche à la france a su miser sa part
été au premier tour en tous les cas un
grand succès donc ça veut dire que c'est
ça va être intéressant de savoir là ce
qui est quand même des policiers
coalition qui se sont formés pour le
deuxième tour si un plus un font d'eux
et en politique on sait que ce n'est pas
toujours le cas
donc là on va avoir un prix saint puy
saint front + 1 503 on va voir on va
voir ce que ça donne tout l'enjeu
notamment en ile de france emmanuel
c'est que cette alliance
cette union de l'union des gauches a pu
parfois provoquer des mouvements de
rejet à l'intérieur même de ces réseaux
si cette union des gauches je peux
dépasser le cadet delà du concept des
gauches irréconciliables
c'est d'ailleurs deux ans je sais est ce
que effectivement comme la div
les scores du premier tour
s'additionnent dans un voilà dans un
corps électoral qui en tout cas dans ses
volumes banalement j'allais peut-être
qu'il ya des gens qui sont sortis il
peut de plus puis d'autres qui sont
rentrés et qui ont décidé de voter que
pour ce second tour
mais est-ce que ça va s'additionner et
est ce que ça va créer une dynamique
parce que en l'occurrence à l'issue du
premier tour l'addition des trois listes
de gauche qui ont fusionné resté en deçà
pour 2 3 points du score de premier tour
de valérie pécresse
enfin il ya un dernier point quand même
pardonnez moi de terminer par une baisse
assez calme est important il nous reste
un peu moins de deux minutes pour en
parler mais c'est la république en
marche et le parti présidentiel qui a
réalisé on le rappelle 10 et demi pour
cent au
au premier tour les chances de gagner
une région sont assez minces ce soir
qu'elle se sait quelle serait la
performance qu'est ce que doit entrer
qu'à espérer le parti présidentiel
sauf profonds bouleversements qui
pourrait mériter des tests de
politologie effectivement s'attend pas à
ce qu'on a vu des choses le japon ne
soient remportées par la république en
marche qui voudrait dire si les choses
sont dans la continuité que le parti
présidentiel a perdu cette élection dès
le premier tour
alors ce sera intéressant de voir
comment se comportent les électeurs au
second tour mais surtout cela république
en marche n'apparaît pas dans ces
élections comme le rempart à celui dont
on a beaucoup parlé c'était le
rassemblement national
on aura donc maintenant dans une minute
et demie pendant que charlotte barillon
reprend possession du point info qui
dont elle nous donnera justement à
partir duquel elle nous donnera la
synthèse des premières informations des
premières déclarations des premières
réactions et bien sûr des premiers
résultats dans une minute maintenant
nous saurons quelle est la physionomie
politique à un an de la présidentielle
pour cette soirée qui reste quand même
une soirée importante une soirée presque
historique dans la mesure où nous aurons
la radiographie de la france politique a
donc moins d'un an du scrutin qui doit
nommer le locataire ou la locataire de
l'elysée on l'a entendu
les enjeux sont différents selon les
parties est ce que les régions dans
lesquelles vont connaître des profonds
bouleversements
est ce qu'il y a des surprises à
attendre de ce second tour
est ce que les présidents sortants comme
on a pu le pressentir au soir du premier
tour vont pouvoir être reconduit toutes
ces réponses maintenant dans un peu
moins de 20 secondes ce qui est
intéressant également c'est le score de
l'abstention qui est à peu près voisin
de celui qu'on a vu au premier tour 66
pour cent au dernier pointage contre
72% de la 66 72 % c'était au premier
tour il est 20 heures
et voici donc les résultats qu'on peut
vous montrer qu'on peut annoncer ce soir
vous allez les voir d'une minute à
l'autre
c'est là donc la droite qui arrive en
tête encore de ce premier tour avec vous
le voyez plus de 38% des voix suivi de
l'alliance gauche et écologistes avec 34
ennemis pour cent des voix le
rassemblement national 20 5% et la
république en marche et le modem qui
font moins de 7% au niveau des régions
ce que l'on peut déjà annoncer c'est une
large victoire de renaud muselier en
provence alpes côte d'azur avec aux
alentours de 55% on aura les résultats
dans un peu plus ben voila vous les avez
56%
donc selon ifop fiducial dans les hauts
de france c'est la victoire comme
attendu de xavier bertrand qui voit là
on va le voir arriver dépasse donc des
50 % 51 9% devant la liste du
rassemblement national de sébastien
chenu avec 26 5% et karima delli qui
améliore son score du premier tour 21 6
% en région au now auvergne rhône-alpes
laurent wauquiez transforme sans
surprise le laisser du premier tour avec
54 6% devant la liste de gauche et des
écologistes que le jce 33 5 % et loin
devant le rassemblement national qui
fait un score inférieur à celui du
premier tour avec 11 9%
on a également des résultats en
bourgogne franche comté où la socialiste
sortante marie-guite dufay est déclaré
vainqueur on a également des résultats
en occitanie ou carole delga améliore
son score de
deux mini 2015 avec plus de 50%
également en nouvelles aquitaine ou à la
rousset arrive nettement en tête et donc
est déclaré vainqueur avec vous voyez 39
2% devant la liste du rassemblement
national et nicolas nicolas florian des
républicains qui fait jeu égal avec les
écologistes et qui passe devant la liste
menée par la ministre modène geneviève
darrieussecq et enfin en bretagne c'est
le sortant loïg chesnais girard qui est
déclaré vainqueur avec aux alentours de
30% un premier commentaire
yves on peut dire déjà que c'est la
victoire des sortantes ce soir oui si la
victoire des sortants on l'avait déjà la
tendance et il existait déjà l'année
dernière on avait vu que c'était la
prime au sortant
ceux qui se sont déplacés ils sont allés
confirmé le président qui exerçait il ya
quelques enseignements comme ça il
faudrait rentrer davantage dans le
détail mais d'abord la bonne tenue de la
droite effectivement qui écrase le match
on va dire qu'ils écrasent le match la
déculottée
on peut le dire comme ça du
rassemblement national alors évidemment
il n'avait pas hyper de rien puisqu'il
n'avait rien on peut l'interpréter comme
ça mais leur score est quand même très
faible quand vous voyez une monsieur
cochrane en rhône-alpes il est 11 % le
score de sébastien chenu et très faible
dans les hauts de france 1 il fait
autour de 26%
il améliore pas son score du premier
tour en tous les cas où très peu on voit
que monsieur mariani il est très très
loin quand même un de monsieur
il ya huit points d'écart 1 pas loin de
8 points d'écart même peut-être plus que
ça douze points d'écart entre mariani et
muselier dans la région provence alpes
côte d'azur donc ça c'est la deuxième
enseignement c'est que leur
rassemblement national est très loin
d'avoir connu le succès et puis
troisième enseignement et bien troisième
enseigne on sait que la république en
marche et modem alors le modem est
installé
territorialement mais l'habit comarch
les quasiment pas en tous les cas dans
les régions et dans les départements et
c'est un loupé total c'est un échec
total pour le parti du président de la
république et on va voir les
conséquences que ça pourra avoir
d'ailleurs pour la présidentielle je
suis pas persuadé que ça des ca et un
impact si vous voulez sur l'élection
présidentielle ça reste alain climat
quand même ça montre que est bien le
président est tout seul et c'est un
homme seul c'est un président seul et
qui n'est pas entourée d'une d'une
formation qui tient la route c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire est ce qu'on peut
gagner dans ces conditions là on verra
il sortait de nulle part quand il a
gagné en 2017
il faut quand même le dire la politique
était assez est assez étonnante
il n'y a pas de règle fixe est de règle
absolument je dirais logique dans un
scrutin politique je réponds à col argo
qui n'ont qu'à les quels sont les
résultats en paca et bien en paca on est
en mesure de vous dire que c'est une
large victoire pour le président sortant
renaud muselier aux alentours de 55% 56%
selon ifop d'autres instituts de même le
crédite de 57% un autre internaute nous
dit emmanuel que c'est une véritable
déroute pour le rn ce soir est-ce que
c'est aussi votre analyse c'est une
contre performance qui confirme celle du
premier tour d'abord c'est le grand
enseignement de ce second tour c'est
qu'on a à peu près les mêmes électeurs
finalement sans doute en tout cas il ya
une grande logique très peu de variation
entre les deux tours donc finalement
c'est cette même france qui est allé
voter deux fois malheureusement ça
représente qu'un tiers des pierres des
français
sur le cas de pâques à ce très
intéressant parce que certes la
progression de thierry mariani est
légèrement supérieure celle de marion
maréchal parce qu'il partait de plus bas
il fait à peu près à peu près le même
score
le front républicain c'est pas tant que
ça fissures et donc à rebours finalement
à ce que nous dit un internaute
d'ailleurs est la vôtre
on se disait on va peut-être un électeur
de la république en marche habituelle et
qu'il a avait voté socialiste canal ex
qu'au sein des électeurs de la
république en marche qui avait fait
cette espèce de deux pas de un peu peu
convaincant dans un premier temps au
tour de renaud muselier
évidemment c'était assez naturelle mais
visiblement les électeurs de gauche
ils ont à peu près suivi comme en 2000
en 2015 l'idée qu'il fallait empêcher le
rassemblement national de d'emporter une
région ça rappelle quelque chose qu'on a
pu voir un petit peu interrogé danse
plusieurs de nos enquêtes à la fois on
désirait pas que le rassemblement
national la porte une région c'était le
parti dont on se disait le plus
mécontents ce qu'il emportait la
présidence de sa propre région et on se
sentait pas une énergie farouche pour
l'empêcher ça reste vrai il me fait de
gens qui sont pas allés voter
il ya une abstention massive dans une
région dont on aurait pu penser qu'elle
allait être emporté par thierry mariani
mais pour ceux qui sont allés voter et
qui sont retournés sans doute voter bah
ils ont voulu empêcher que ça arrive
après les électeurs sont allés au
secours de la victoire ça c'est frappant
c'est surtout pour la droite
effectivement mais notamment parce que
la droite était en tête dans davantage
de régions parce que sortant dans
davantage de régions et des progressions
très très nette après et des paris qui
ont été plus ou moins
réussi celui d'alain rousset de se
passer des écologistes voilà il a montré
qu'il pouvait qu'il pouvait le faire
le hic chesnais-girard bailly les
gagnants avec -2 33% dans le cas d'une
canne singulair il va pas avoir la
majorité sur sa liste il va être obligé
de composer des écologistes pour
constituer une majorité sans doute alors
si ces résultats seraient cela parce que
rappelons que en dessous de 30 3%
la prime majoritaire ne permet pas
d'avoir une majorité à l'assemblée
régionale alors xavier bertrand se dit
prêt à aller à la rencontre de tous les
français une brève réaction va peut-être
le réentendre dans un instant le
président donc des hauts de france c'est
on va attendre d'ailleurs d'avoir pour
justement un peu plus analysé la
performance de xavier bertrand les
résultats en ile-de-france pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de résultats
moins que vous en ayez pour valérie
pécresse qui était donnée selon les
dernières projections de selon les
derniers sondages nettement nettement en
tête mais pour l'instant on n'a pas vu
encore d
des résultats à noter la performance de
quand même on disait pour le
gouvernement celle de gérard darel
gérald darmanin qui est élu à 65% dans
son fief de tourcoing et qui améliore
d'ailleurs son score aux municipales
idem pour un autre ministre sébastien
lecornu qui fait 75 % dans son canton de
vernon dans l'eure et permet à la
république en marche de garder sa
majorité ce soir c'est bien le seul lot
de consolation d'ailleurs que peut avoir
le parti présidentiel
oui bah c'est sûr mais je pense que le
parti présidentiel avait fait son deuil
de cette élection c'est évident qu'ils
la trêve à les appréhender et d'abord il
appréhender on avait compris que le
président de la république voulait que
ça reste un scrutin local et puis c'est
lui qui d'une certaine façon la
nationaliser en envoyant des ministres
ici ou là notamment dans les hautes
france contre probablement un ses futurs
adversaires qui est déviée bertrand donc
là un changement de cap
comme à chaque fois tu vers les
élections locales sont de très mauvaises
élections on l'a vu avec les municipales
et régionales cette fois les
départementales pour la majorité
présidentielle
et c'est le scrutin des européennes qui
avaient été un peu une surprise quand
même il faut le dire à la haye la sortie
du commandant du mouvement des gilets
jaunes de voir que finalement le
président et le parent est présent de la
république et sa liste se maintenait
à peu près bien alors que j'aille heures
la tête de liste était quand même pas
très populaire n'avait pas fait une
campagne exceptionnelle
donc voilà ce qui peut ce qu'il peut
être dit juste un commentaire peut-être
un autre résultat qui vient de tomber
cette fois ci c'est en corse où le
nationaliste gilles simeoni remporte
également l'élection alors ce qu'ils
voudraient d'ailleurs dire que sur les
régions métropolitaines pour l'instant
pas de changement jeu max est absolument
bouleversant parce qu'en 2010 la même
manière les seuls changements de région
s'était fait dans en outre-mer et là on
a une stabilité de la carte régionale
qui s'annonce alors on va attendre
qu'ils soient leurs pour donner les
résultats en ile de france mais c'est
vrai que si on applique les logiques que
l'on a commenté depuis qu'on a les
résultats à 20h avec yves donc emmanuel
rivière prend le pari de vous dire que
valérie les logiques qu'on constate dans
toutes les régions seraient très démenti
si on n'avait pas ce résultat-là en
ile-de-france lorsqu on en aura les
résultats
il ya un autre résultat justement qui
confiance que vous dites c'est dans le
grand est où le sortant républicain jean
rottner qui avait refusé la
l'alliance avec la république en marche
et dernier largement également en tête
est donné largement vainqueur avec 39%
des voix et il devance laurent jacot
belli le porte parole du rassemblement
national de 12 points et avec le parti
socialiste qui arrivent et les écolos et
le pcf qui arrive en troisième position
devant la ministre
ancien élève brigitte klinkert avec 12
8% des voix cela c'est une estimation
qui est donnée par ipsos steria
peut-être un commentaire sur sur cette
stratégie qui est menée par jean rottner
qui était de refuser de faire finalement
alliance ou de tendre la main à la
république en marche finalement cette
stratégie-là a été plutôt payante
oui elle a été payante c'était une
personne ne voulait s'allier avec la
majorité présidentielle et vous avez vu
combien il ya une exception qui était
quand même la région provence alpes côte
d'azur parce que si le parti des
républicains n'avaient pas tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé
peut-être que je dirais la lie à une
coalition entre deux cas une fusion des
deux candidatures entre la majorité
présidentielle et les républicains a pu
avoir lieu sous la houlette de renaud
muselier mai
les républicains n'avaient pas intérêt à
s'allier avec la république en marche
parce qu'il ya justement il ya un
présidentielle de l'année prochaine et
le score très médiocre sinon très
mauvais de la république en marche était
prévisible donc là publics avaient tout
intérêt à faire cavalier seul dans cette
histoire la droite est désormais la
seule force d'alternance c'est ce que
vient de déclarer christian jacob à
l'instant là toute la problématique est
tout le problème pour la droite pour
reprendre un commentaire une analyse
cave et yves tout à l'heure ça va être
d'avoir un leader qui incarne cette
alternative par rapport à mal macron
whisky et la situation paradoxale des
républicains c'est qu'on ne sait jamais
trouvé si près de l'échéance sans avoir
en son sein soit un leader très
identifiés et voilà nicolas sarkozy en
2007 avait tué le match qui aurait pu
l'opposer éventuellement à dominique de
villepin alors une amende 2017 c'est un
petit peu différent mais on avait sur
les rangs pour la bataille pour les
primaires deux anciens premiers
ministres un ancien président de la
république
donc on pouvait penser que les primaires
à les sélectionner parmi ces trois là un
candidat extrêmement costaud et sa
situation elle se produit malgré tout
dans alors c'est tout à fait de bonne
guerre de la part de christian jacob
dire voilà c'est la principale la
principale force
sauf que moi quand on est représentant
d'un parti politique ce soir quel qu'il
soit on compte surtout la faiblesse
avoir mobilisé donc on est dans un
paysage extrêmement fluide extrêmement
incertain instable où il faut d'urgence
remettre en cohérence
ce que veut dire la proposition d'un
parti politique sur les grands enjeux
par un seul enjeu on en supposant que la
présidentielle se jouerait sur un enjeu
mais rappelez quand on a un grand parti
qui a vocation à gouverner qu'on a des
réponses sur la principes et les
articuler et donner des raisons d'y
croire
surtout ce qui préoccupe les français
oublié que le paysage politique
aujourd'hui il est sinistré avec 65 ou
70% d'abstention 66% au dernier pointage
mon cher et emmanuel si vous nous
rejoignez donc sachez que les présidents
sortants à part pour l'instant nous
attendons toujours les résultats en
ile-de-france sont donnés vainqueurs ce
soir dans les quatorze autres grandes
région en tous les cas en métropole
parce que pour l'instant les résultats
en outre-mer nous ne sont pas encore
parvenus mais on peut dire que encore en
paca en occitanie en nouvelles aquitaine
au pays dans les pays de la loire alors
dans les pays de la loire on n'a pas
encore de projection mais moi il me
semble avoir vu que chris tellement
c'était quand même donné largement en
tête
et bien justement meurt on me dit qu'on
l'a on va regarder justement les
résultats donc dans les pays de la loire
avec christelle morancé qui est donné
avec une dizaine de points derrière la
liste qui la liste d'alliance donc
europe ecologie les verts et socialistes
et devant le rassemblement national et
devant également la république en marche
qui est intéressant on le disait tout à
l'heure
emmanuel sur les pays de la loire c'est
que les listes rassemblement national et
lrm danser dans cette région là on
ont perdu par rapport aussi aux
précédents précédents tours ce qui se
produit en général quand des électeurs
se disent bombe pour la liste que j'ai
choisi au premier tour de toute façon
c'est fichu mais il ya encore quelque
chose qui peut jouer l'or c'est vrai
qu'il ya quelque chose qui ressemblait à
un suspense dans les pays-de-la-loire
parce que pour le coup et l'addition des
listes de monsieur garraud et de
monsieur orphelins crois que vous allez
bertrand est en train de parler
alors on va lui laisser la parole alors
on va on va l'entendre d'une minute à
l'autre
juste peut-être les pays de la loire
avec cette victoire de cristal morancé
c'est un échec peut également pour les
écologistes baala c'est un gros échec
parce qu'on pensait que ça c'est
et ils ont bien voulu les montrer
c'est lui la france comme on va le voir
le lobait le plus fort
et où les services qui y séjournent en
dc2 cette région vous laissiez les amis
du monde
durant ce sens bien
ce résultat ne leur ai dit ce que l'on
est en effet la sécurité les figures et
ce sourire
les premières montres ces violences
[Musique]
la diviser mon objectif c'est que le
travail paye à nouveau pour élever ses
enfants
ma priorité ce sont les classes moyennes
et les catégories populaires ceux qui
ont applaudi lors du premier confinement
avant de les oublier à nouveau pour cela
tournons la page
tournons la page et les sons respirer
les français laissons respirer les
territoires bâtissons ensemble un
nouveau projet de société pour mieux
vivre partout c'est cela la république
des territoires que vous ayez voté ou
pas je vous le dis ce soir nous avons
besoin de vous notre nation a besoin de
vous de chacun d'entre vous de votre
patriotisme de votre volonté farouche de
voir la france retrouver le premier rang
par delà la colère et les souffrances il
y a un chemin d'espoir il vient du coeur
des territoires
depuis cette france fière digne
courageuse et qui va reprendre en main
son destin ce chemin de l'espoir
il démarre maintenant il démarre ici
vivent les hôtes france des blats
république et vive la france
voilà vous venez d'entendre xavier
bertrand avec un discours à tonalité
assez sociale ont valeur on va
l'entendre
on a également laurent wauquiez qui est
en train de prendre la parole à lyon et
c'est en train d'arriver
laurent wauquiez qui a été largement ray
les français sont exaspérés
quand on ne réagit pas par rapport à
ceux qui dégradent la france ce soir les
extrêmes ont reculé fortement dans notre
région car nous ne leur laisserons aucun
terrain pour prospérer et de la même
manière je crois dans la préférence
locale je crois dans la relocalisation
de nos entreprises je suis convaincu
qu'il faut ramener la production dans
notre territoire plutôt que d'importer
ce qui vient de l'extérieur c'est mieux
pour l'emploi c'est mieux pour
l'environnement et il nous faut demain
plus de protection vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur et plus de liberté à
l'intérieur - de normes moins de charges
moins de harcèlement administratif et ce
cap clair enfin c'est celui de la
fidélité à des valeurs fortes
la politique n'est pas belle dans la
lâcheté la politique ne se grandit pas
dans l'ironie quand la politique n'est
belle que quand on assume des idées qui
sont fortes
le travail plutôt que l'assistanat la
promotion du mérite plutôt que le
nivellement par le bas
la défense de notre mode de vie plutôt
que les compromis avec le
communautarisme la bonne gestion plutôt
que l'argent magique
toutes ces valeurs sont celles qui
permettent de tenir debout
les français attendent cela ils
attendent du courage
ils attendent le chemin du bon sens et
ils attendent la reconstruction pour
notre pays
tout est là nous avons en nous tous les
atouts nous avons en nous toutes les
forces pour sortir de la crise et seul
un cap clair permettra de trouver une
nouvelle espérance
merci à tous
voilà vous voulez entendre donc
successivement xavier bertrand et
laurent wauquiez tous les deux réélus
alain à la tête des hauts de france et
laurent wauquiez réélu dans la province
dans la ford dans la région rhône alpes
auvergne
peut-être un commentaire yves sur cette
séquence où ils ont parlé quasiment l'un
et l'autre en même temps bah oui ça y
est j'ai l'impression ça donne
l'impression que la course est lancée à
la compétition pour la présidentielle
valérie pécresse est lancée ils ont tous
tous les deux un discours volontairement
je dirais assez nationale finalement il
parle cercle de leur région mais les
thèmes qu'ils ne développent sont des
thèmes qui peuvent avoir une vocation
nationale un écho national et il est sûr
qu'on va voir leurs intentions la
tension de guy bertrand elle et elle a
été déclaré il n'appartient pas aux
républicains je rappelle qu'il avait
qu'il a dit que quoi qu'il arrive il
irait et que ne se retirerait pas et
c'est bien là le problème parce que
on peut y avoir un candidat officiel
derrière munich a officialisé lundi
bertrand je ne pense pas qu'ils fassent
cette erreur là mais s'il aventure
c'était le cas ce serait là la droite se
tirerait une balle dans le pied à coup
sûr en vue du deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle alors que là
on le voit même si une abstention forte
le la droite est en mesure de bousculer
le jeu et les pronostics qui valent ce
qu'ils valent conduisait vers une une
finale le pen
macron dans un match retour est loin
d'être évidente
parce qu'on peut d'ailleurs leur tordre
définitivement le cou à ces évidences
tout fait on compte plus souvent le
nombre de fois on a cru que le second
tour allait être celui qu'on pensait que
le nombre de fois où effectivement on a
repris les mêmes à l'élection
présidentielle d'après l'ayant la
dernière fois que c'est arrivé
c'était il ya 40 ans il était en 1980
depuis ça n'est plus jamais arrivé sauf
qu'on ya cru très fort en 2002 on ya cru
un petit peu on après entre 2012 et 2017
pas trop entre 2007 et 2012 et c'est pas
la règle veut reprendre les deux mêmes
c'est pas la règle donc le jeu est
effectivement extrêmement ouvert on
annonce justement barré de l'open qui
doit s'exprimer
je donne rendez vous aux français dès
demain pour construire tous ensemble
l'alternance dont la france a besoin
c'était court donc je pense qu'on va ré
avoir la fp va redonner l'intégralité de
la déclaration de marine le pen mais
effectivement il ya eu peut-être de
l'embouteillage dans les envois donc dès
que on l'aura aidé que ce sera justement
renvoyé par les afp on vous le
transmettra effectivement donc marine le
pen c'est une soirée qui est assez dure
pour elle on imagine
je voudrais revenir justement sur le
contenu de ce qu'ont déclaré à la fois
xavier bertrand et laurent wauquiez
arrêtez moi si je me trompe mais j'ai
l'impression quand même que c'était une
tonalité assez social un discours assez
social chez bertrand et un discours
assez droitier avec des thèmes quand
même qu'ils sont pas loin de certains
prisé par le rassemblement national chez
laurent wauquiez oui c'est effectivement
on à la france qui travaille dans le
nord cette thématique sociale de la
france des invisibles des oubliés donc
voila c'était un peu l'accent de dali
bertrand c'est normal il a aussi cette
fibre là un lui il a toujours revendiqué
une espèce de séguinisme dans son
discours il fait partie d'eux ils
revendiquent d'appartenir à la france
social j'ai à la droite sociale pardon
chez laurent wauquiez bas il y a
aussi bon il a été question de
souveraineté de
la france des territoires ce sont des
thèmes assez classique finalement et qui
peut porter qui peut le porter aux
élections à l'élection présidentielle
c'est on va retrouver d'ailleurs le même
discours vraisemblablement gp presse qui
sera un discours empreint de 2-2-2 de
sécurité d'emploi de liberté c'est un
discours que tu assez classique
alors peut-être qu'on va ré entendre
marine le pen s'exprimer
s'abstenir de participer à cette
séquence et l'hôtel départemental et
régional
une absence totale d'information mais
une organisation désastreuse et
erratique des scrutins par le ministre
de l'intérieur
la sortie d'un interminable compliment
un désenchantement à l'égard des
élections intermédiaires que le civisme
et la lucidité des électeurs du fn qui
affronte apporté leurs voix à nos
candidats soit loué ce soir nous ne
prendrons pas de région puisque des
sortants à l'aide d' alliances contre
nature ont tout fait nous empêcher de
montrer aux français notre capacité à
diriger un exécutif régional
la progression très importante entre les
deux tours en paca qui reste tout de
même insuffisante pour offrir la
victoire démontre que la mobilisation
est la clé des victoires à venir
nombreuse élu ce soir défendrons par
tous les intérêts des habitants avec un
mot d'ordre vous protéger et lorsque
deux français sur trois persiste à ne
pas voter en particulier les jeunes et
les classes populaires c'est évidemment
un message qui doit nous interpeller car
cette désaffection civique historique
constitue un signal majeur lancé à toute
la classe politique et même à toute la
société
nous vivons une crise profonde de la
démocratie locale qui nécessite un
travail de réflexion collectif méthodes
de mobilisation représentativité
informations des électeurs
proportionnelle référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
tout doit être aujourd'hui débattu pour
rendre à nos compatriotes le goût de
décider de leur avenir
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
mettre toute mon énergie et ma volonté à
réhabiliter la politique à lui rendre
son utilisent
et son efficacité au bénéfice des
français parce que la présidentielle
apparaît plus que jamais comme
l'élection qui permet de changer de
politique et de changer les politiques
et que les français nous apportent leur
soutien dans cette mission
je donne rendez vous aux français dès
demain pour construire tous ensemble
l'alternance dont la france a besoin ce
qui est intéressant quand on entend
marine le pen
dire cela c'est que on peut pas
s'empêcher de mettre ça en écho avec ce
qu'elle dit le soir du deuxième tour des
présidentielles où elle dit que le
rassemblement national et son parti est
la première force d'opposition
ce qui n'est plus le cas ce soir puisque
le front national le rassemblement
national fait 25 % contre 27 % au
deuxième tour des élections de 2015 oui
nos normes et c'est une très mauvaise
élection pour les élections pour les
pour leur assemblée nationale c'est un
scrutin qui a montré ses faiblesses qui
a montré aussi en dépit faut être très
prudent parce qu'il ya une abstention
qui est tel que faut pas tirer non plus
trop de generali trop de conclusions
hâtives mais il ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à l'intérieur du front national du
rassemblement national
il va y avoir un débat sur la stratégie
d'ouverture de madame le pen est ce que
le ton qui consiste à recentrer le parti
par rapport à l'europe par rapport au
droit du travail par rapport à plusieurs
sujets qui a été adopté par madame le
pen qui est beaucoup moins agressive
beaucoup moins dur que par le passé
c'est le bon probablement qu'il va qui
vont estimer que non et le fait
d'appeler et de tendre la main vers des
élus ou des figures politiques qui ne
sont pas je dirais des pur produit
maison c'était le cas dans les hauts de
france c'était le cas de monsieur
kottaras qu en région rhône alpes
auvergne qui vient de la france
insoumise et
il ya énormément de république garant
pacage mariani monsieur gare aux rixes
thani monsieur mariani en paca monsieur
sébastien chenu en autre en souviennent
des républicains donc est ce que ces
stratégies va être va continuer à être
approuvé c'est tout ça qui va être en
débat à mon avis à l'intérieur des
républicains opération nationale c'est
un congrès à partir de la semaine
prochaine à perpignan
il ya trois sujets en fait qui semble
peser aujourd'hui en tout cas ce soir
sur les performances du rassemblement
national
le premier c'est que ça commence à faire
longtemps qu'ils sont dans le paysage
politique sans débouchés on connaît pas
d'équivalent en europe d'un parti
politique à la droite de la droite comme
ça qu'ils une vocation rupture east deux
parties de protestataires et qu'ils se
soient à ce point installé ensuite s'il
ya effectivement l'évolution de son
discours qui a pu déconcerter un certain
nombre de gens et ses ouvertures pas
très réussie en fait je vais faire
injure à personne ni à monsieur quotas
monsieur mariani
non mais laisse que les scores les
scores lundi comprend par exemple paca
effectivement ou qui allie mariani va
vraiment sable en faire moins que ne
l'avait fait marion maréchal-le pen aux
dernières élections régionales et jean
paul garraud en occitanie
donc en occitanie fait nettement moins
que louis aliot aux dernières régionales
dans ce dans cette région là donc vous
n'êtes injure à personne mais ce n'est
pas la fin il faut un moment où regarder
plus largement quand on commente
l'évolution de ces partis dits populiste
monsieur salvini en italie accède au
pouvoir parce qu'à un moment il s'est
entendu avec monsieur berlusconi c'est
autre chose que de faire venir
monsieur kottaras comme monsieur mariani
dans ses rangs merci pour ces premières
analyses perceive on vous nous quittez
maintenant mais on vous retrouve dans
dallas dans une heure et demie sur le
plateau de la chaîne parlementaire et de
public sénat
c'est ça ou vous serez présent dans
notre cette soirée en partenariat avec
figaro live on va faire le point sur les
dernières déclarations les premières
déclarations les premières analyses les
derniers résultats
juste pour vous dire peut-être que
valérie pécresse et selon les premières
estimations données en tête est donné
vainqueur en ile de france mais je vous
en dis pas plus le reste c'est charlotte
barioz dang huy qui va nous le dire
bonsoir à tous merci de me retrouver
pour ce point info que je vais vous
livrer régulièrement tout au long de
cette soirée jusqu'à 22h merci vincent
de me donner la parole effectivement
valérie pécresse l'emportent en ile de
france avec 45 5% des voix selon les
premières estimations
au plan national la droite arrive en
tête avec 38% des voix à l'échelle
nationale selon les premières
estimations il faut fiducial les
républicains et leurs alliés
apparaissent donc comme la première
force politique à un an de la
présidentielle la droite est arrivé en
tête devant la gauche et europe écologie
les verts qui récolte 34 5% des voix
suivi par le rassemblement national avec
25% des voix
la république en marche comptabilise 7 %
des voix à l'échelle nationale toujours
selon ces premières estimations
communiquées depuis 20 heures ce soir
autre chiffre en auvergne rhône-alpes
laurent wauquiez est réélu facilement
avec 54 6% des voix le président et
l'air sortant de la région l'a largement
emporté lors de ce second tour devant
l'écologiste fabienne grébert et le rn
andrea cataractes en bretagne loïg
chesnais-girard 2
socialistes conservent la région le
président socialiste sortant n'est
cependant pas certain de parvenir à
obtenir la majorité au conseil régional
il pourrait devoir faire face à un
troisième tour en bourgogne franche
comté la socialiste marie-guite dufay
est réélu malgré une cadre angulaire
alors que le risque le pénis était
élevée la présidente socialiste sortante
alliés ouvert l'a finalement emporté au
second tour en centre val de loire le
socialiste françois bonneau conserve la
région selon les premières estimations
le président sortant a recueilli 39 %
des voix lors de ce second tour ce
dimanche 27 juin 2021
dans le grand est maintenant jean
rottner dlr est reconduit pour six ans
le président sortant a été élu pour ce
deuxième mandat avec 39% des voix lors
de ce second tour
en paca le républicain renaud muselier
l'a emporté face à thierry mariani du
rassemblement national avec 56% des voix
contre 44% des voix il prive le
rassemblement national de sa seule
chance de remporter une région je vous
laisse la parole vincent vaut à tout à
l'heure pour un autre point info et
c'est julien bayou qui va prendre la
parole il dit est en train de s'exprimer
en ce moment julien bayou qui est donc
donné la ga perdante devra le
gouvernement devra s'expliquer sur le
fiasco de la gestion de ce scrutin
je dénonce aussi la violence de cette
campagne les injures les diffamations
répétées de nos adversaires et la mise
en avant le thème qui relèvent pas de la
compétence régionale a fini de brouiller
le message est de détourner les
électrices et les électeurs du scrutin
malgré le net recul de la participation
je dois noter que les écologistes ont
progressé en voix et en pourcentage
passant de 8 à 13% au premier tour et
une analyse région par région démontre
un enracinement de notre mouvement
pour
quoi qu'il arrive ce soir nous devrions
à minima doubler le nombre d'élus dans
les conseils régionaux et doubler
également le nombre d'élus dans les
conseils départementaux qs percée aux
européennes ancrage aux municipales
consolidation et enracinement aux
régionales et aux départementales en
tant que secrétaire national évidemment
je m'en réjouis et je constate que
l'écologie est la seule force en
dynamique
la mission est remplie la feuille de
route est claire et le résultat est très
encourageant et je voudrais prendre un
mot pour féliciter toutes nos têtes de
liste c'est karima delli dans les hauts
de france éliane romani ans grant est
claire desmares poirier en bretagne
laetitia sanchez en normandie
stéphanie modde en bourgogne franche
comté
fabienne grébert en auvergne rhône-alpes
charles fournier ans entre val de loire
antoine maurice en occitanie nicolas
thierry en nouvelles aquitaine jean
pierre marchau à la réunion et bien sûr
au salut jean-laurent fille lydia en
paca
partout où nos candidats et candidates
sont arrivés en tête
nous nous avons su créer les conditions
du rassemblement autour d'un projet qui
porte l écologie la justice sociale et
la démocratie quand les ténèbres menace
il ne faut pas maudire l'obscurité
il faut allumer une lumière et cette
lumière
nous l'avons allumé ensemble et nous
gardons au coeur les milliers les
milliers de sourires et d'encouragements
croisé dans cette campagne au second
tour l'union n'est jamais simple et il
restera toujours des hommes et des
femmes irréconciliables mais pour nous
ils appartiennent déjà au passé et
l'heure est venue de tourner cette page
au delà de nos différences nous
connaissons maintenant le chemin qu'il
faut prendre pour faire gagner le valeur
c'est celui de l'écologie celle
écologique est en dynamique
c'est l'écologie qui rassemble et c'est
l'affirmation de l'écologie qui pose les
conditions d'une alternative victorieuse
je veux me tourner vers l'avenir et vous
dire que l'heure est venue d'écrire une
nouvelle page de l'histoire que la
gauche et l'écolo et l'écologie sont de
retour
et si la victoire n'est pas au rendez
vous ce soir partout nous l'espérions
elle arrivera demain merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
julien bayou donc qui réalise selon les
estimations notamment d'ifop fiducial
32,5 pour cent des voix donc 13 points
derrière valérie pécresse qui est donc
la grande vainqueur en ile-de-france la
présidente sortante recueille 45 5% des
voix et derrière jordan bardella qui
recule 11,5 et vous le voyez laurent
saint martin le candidat de la
république en marche qui lui également
recul et avec dix émis pour cent des
voix on salue guillaume roquette qui
vient de nous rejoindre directeur de la
rédaction du figaro magazine et
présentateur de points de vue sur fear
alive guillaume à l'instant julien bayou
déploré ceux qui parlaient
ces hommes et ces femmes qui
irréconciliables on voit bien l'allusion
à ce que manuel valls appelle les deux
gauches irréconciliables et on se
souvient que manuel valls a appelé à ne
pas voter pour cette liste d'union de la
gauche
on sent poindre là
la colère du leader écologiste derrière
cette stratégie qui finalement semble
avoir été fatal à la liste d'union de la
gauche en ile-de-france effectivement ni
manuel valls naples et a voté pour cette
liste ni même et peut-être surtout jean
paul huchon qui avait été président de
la région ile de france pendant au moins
deux mandats c'est mes souvenirs sont
exacts mais peut-être même 3 effective
entrevoir mandat et ce qui est certain
c'est que cette gauche cette gauche arc
en ciel cette gauche rouge verte rose
avec l'alliance des socialistes des
écologistes et de la france insoumise
ça n'a pas fait on le voit aussi dans la
région hôte france où il y avait
pourtant dès le premier tour
une gauche unie donc on aurait pu
imaginer une dynamique et il me semble
que cet échec est à l'image de ce que
sont ces élections c'est à dire une
situation incroyablement stable
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de
dynamique nulle part il ya il ya les
sortants qui semble-t-il vont ils pas
dynamique à droite ja non il n'y a pas
vraiment de dynamique à droite il ya une
dynamique à droite parce que là où les
présidents de droite sont sortants ils
sont réélus et confortablement donc la
droite confortent cet ancrage local
mais au premier tour dans les régions où
la droite n'était pas à sortante c'est à
dire où le président était était de
gauche et bien le score de la droite
était tout sauf faramineux donc il y a
eu avant toute chose un vote de
confirmation
un vote de c'était le contraire du
dégagisme cette élection je pense que
personne ne peut en tirer
d'enseignements en triomphant en disant
ça y est on est élu ce qui est vrai
quand même c'est que
conforter ses positions dans le
dans les territoires à voir voilà c'est
peut-être une trop une abondance de bien
mais avoir des présidentiables de droite
qui sont renforcées c'est une situation
qui est quand même plus favorables que
celles du rassemblement national qui
s'est pris objectivement une claque ou
celles dans marche qui n'existe toujours
pas comme parti politique en dehors de
de soutien direct à emmanuel macron sur
le ce soir il y à l'internaute qui le
dit il faut que chaque partie maîtres de
l'écologie dans son programme
on entendait julien bayou féliciter les
têtes de liste écologiste dans
différentes régions
mais on lisait juste avant de l'entendre
c'est pas tellement une performance pour
les pour les écologistes avec notamment
s'est éclipsée par la contre-performance
du rassemblement national mais une
contre performance dans les pays de la
loire le premier tour ne pouvait
apparaître comme une assez bonne
performance pour europe ecologie les
verts puisque dans les régions qu'ils
n'étaient pas détenus par la gauche et
où il était en compétition avec le parti
socialiste notamment dans l'épi la loire
mais également en ile de france ce sont
les listes emmenées par les verts qui
sont sorties en tête du premier tour et
de l'ordonner vocation pas ce qu'était
le cas de lucas mailloux de matthieu
orphelin emmené l'attelage et c'était
dans ces régions là qu'il y avait une
chance de victoire pour cette plage
emmenés par les écologistes et c'est là
où effectivement il ya une déception
notamment par rapport au scénario des
municipales ou bien ces scénarios là
avait abouti à des victoires à
strasbourg à bordeaux à marseille même
si marseille revenu non les mâts la
gestion de quelqu'un issu du parti
socialiste il y avait et à besançon
exactement le même scénario un peu moins
de dépenses en est donc là dessus de
fait il ya une contre-performance qui
pose un certain nombre de questions
parce qu'un parti dans symboliquement on
n'a pas parlé
ce soir et la semaine dernière pas
beaucoup plus c'est la france a soumises
qui pour le coup avant dans un certain
nombre de régions faisait un peu
cavalier seul et s'est retrouvé éliminé
aussi le plus souvent que emmenés dans
des alliances dans des alliances à
gauche les quais l'alliance à gauche en
l'occurrence lorsqu'elle s'est fait en
ile-de-france ont posé un problème de
latitude à cette jambe délectera par
rapport je vous interromps emmanuel
puisque on ne signale que valérie
pécresse est en train de s'exprimer a un
petit souci technique avant que valérie
pécresse ne s'exprime donc desquels
s'exprimera
et bien alors est-ce qu'on est là
signale-t-on
vous me dites qu'en bas vous pouvez y
aller valérie pécresse
je ne sais pas ses deux enfants
aujourd'hui les franciliennes et les
franciliens ont décidé de me renouveler
leur confiance comme présidente de notre
région et je les en remercie du fond du
coeur mais je pense ce soir à tous les
franciliens qui se sont abstenus je
pense aussi à tous ceux qui n'ont pas
voté pour moi et je salue mes
adversaires dans cette campagne
a tous je veux dire ce soir que je
continuerai à diriger la région comme je
lé fais depuis six ans en affirmant mes
convictions bien sûr mais aussi en
restant à l'écouté de toutes les
opinions et sans aucun sectarisme
j'ai été et je serai la présidente de
tous les franciliens
alors cette victoire ce soir elle est
belle elle est belle car elle est
l'aboutissement de nombreuses années
d'engagement de rencontre mais aussi de
travail et de résultats nous avons fait
de la sécurité et de la laïcité de la
qualité 10 et de la solidarité les
valeurs cardinales de nos actions
concrètes
je crois plus que tout à la politique
par la preuve
cette victoire elle est belle car dans
notre région capitale de 12 millions
d'habitants dynamique
une créative mais aussi éruptive est
fracturée nous avons relevé le défi de
la crédibilité et du rassemblement
par delà les clivages et les clivages il
y en a en ile de france entre paris et
la banlieue entre les quartiers
populaires et les centres villes entre
les cartes les territoires urbains et
pétoires ruraux alors cette victoire
elle est belle car comme en 2015
rien n'était écrit nous avons dû engager
nous engager sur quatre fronts d'abord
par notre fermeté notre attention aux
territoires ruraux nous avons fait
baisser le rassemblement national
l'extrême droite
pourtant en extension depuis plusieurs
scrutins par notre clarté nous avons
fait gagner les forces de la droite et
du centre dans une région où la majorité
présidentielle avait décidé d'engager
cinq ministres par notre incarnation
d'une écologie des résultats nous avons
prouvé que l'écologie n'appartenait à
aucun camp enfin par notre attachement
aux valeurs de la république
notre défense de la laïcité de l'égalité
femmes hommes nous l'avons emporté face
à l'alliance du parti socialiste est
d'une extrême gauche qui a perdu sa
boussole républicaine je veux ce soir
exprimer ma profonde gratitude aux
républicains sincères des deux rives qui
se sont mobilisés et rassembler pour
faire barrage aux extrêmes ce combat
difficile mais enthousiasmant je ne vais
pas mener seul j'ai été entouré de
nombreux élus de personnalités de la
société civile de militants et de tous
ses citoyennes et ses citoyens engagés
qui donnent sans compter leur temps y
compris pour tenir les bureaux de vote
je remercie chacun d'eux j'adresse une
pensée particulière et affectueuse à
notre président de comité de soutien le
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
incarne avec force ces valeurs
républicaines que nous voulons défendre
cette confiance renouvelée des
franciliens m'honore elle m'oblige aussi
notre région sub riz subi de nombreuses
turbulences
elle mérite d'être sans cesse réinventée
et ses habitants protéger durant les
prochaines semaines
je mettrai en oeuvre sans attendre mes
engagements de campagne afin de donner
un nouvel élan à notre politique de
sécurité de relance d'écologie concrètes
et d'égalité des chances
tout au long de cette campagne
les franciliens ont reconnu en moi une
femme d'ordre une femme libre
une femme fière de servir sa région et
son pays
ce soir une équipe de france de la
droite et du centre a émergé dans les
régions nous avons une grande
responsabilité et j'y prendrai toute ma
part plus que jamais je veux continuer
et amplifier mon combat pour mes
convictions mais aussi pour les valeurs
de la république de toutes mes forces
vives ile de france
vive la république et vive la france
voilà il convient d'en que vous venez
d'entendre valérie pécresse et on a
également renaud muselier qui s'exprime
depuis donc marseille où il a été
largement réélu président du conseil
régional de paca où la région sud non
plus notre destin en mains en dehors des
appareils politiques rappelant que nous
sommes des femmes et des hommes du sud
libre déterminé passionné résistant et
même modèle au sort de cette victoire la
confiance qui repose sur mes épaules a
deux conséquences
elle nous honore et elle nous oblige
elle nous au nom car est aussi la
reconnaissance de votre esprit de large
rassemblement que nous défendons depuis
le début elle nous oblige
parce que cette confiance en gage nos
élus dès demain matin à livrer toutes
leurs forces à l'aune de cette victoire
du rassemblement tout dans l'action qui
sera conduite devra répondre à cet appel
et s'inspirer de cette exigence
j'ai pris un engagement faire entendre
la voix de toutes les forces politiques
au sein de l'hémicycle du conseil
régional
c'est un engagement formel sur le meur
je confirme
l'engagement au nom de tous les élus qui
m'accompagneront dans ces nouveaux
mandats
mesdames et messieurs depuis le début de
cette campagne je suis entouré par une
équipe de 135 policiers qui a montré sa
résistance face à toutes les épreuves
rien vraiment rien ne nous aura été
épargné aucun mensonge aucune caricature
aucune famille aucune trahison on aura
eu droit à tout mais au coeur de cette
tempête
aucun d'entre nous n'a femme chez jamais
aucune des têtes de liste qui vont
entourer d'un failli je veux remercier
bénédicte martin dans le vaucluse
christian estrosi dans les alpes
maritimes chantal eyméoud dans les
hautes-alpes françois de canson dans le
var sophie joissains mon binôme dans les
bouches-du-rhône et david jehan dans les
alpes de haute provence
aucun des militants qui l'ont entouré
là ménagé ses efforts je vous en suis
infiniment reconnaissant ou pouvaient
être fiers de ce que vous avez accompli
dès le départ
notre stratégie était la bonne personne
ne l'avait vu personne ne l'avait voulu
personne ne l'a vu le suivi personne ne
l'avait comprise
ce soir chacun peut s'en rendre compte
c'était la bonne décision je m'adresser
à nos 5 millions de concitoyens vous
êtes déplacés pour voter aujourd'hui
mais votre tâche n'est pas terminée
demain nous aurons besoin de vous tous
pour faire triompher notre région
d'abord dans ce combat là comme dans les
précédents comme pendant la crise vous
pourrez toujours compter sur moi je
m'adressais aux français qui nous
regardent
je le redis notre région est unique elle
est magnifique elle est spéciale
aujourd'hui nous venons de montrer une
nouvelle fois que nous sommes libres
je m'adressais aux européens qui nous
aurons beaucoup suivi par inquiétude ou
par curiosité
notre région est ouverte elle est belle
elle est forte et puissante elle est
libre il ya les restes laura forte dans
sa direction dans sa gouvernance de son
idéal euro méditerranéen voilà mesdames
et messieurs dans l'intégralité de ses
combats nous avons
notre région d'abord 100% pour nos
territoires 100% pour notre
disponibilité pour notre efficacité et
cette liberté n'a pas de prix
merci à vous tous malgré les
applaudissements pardon mais vous pouvez
le mercure de renommer les traits
triomphale ce soir non parce que
probablement que c'est plus un
soulagement qu'un triomphe et renaud
muselier avait joué gros en faisant cet
accord qui ne disait pas son nom avec la
république en marche dès le premier tour
il se trouvait dans une situation qui
lui était plutôt favorable puisque il y
a eu un front républicain qui de toute
évidence s'est mis en place dans la
région avec à la fois
enfin le avec les le candidat de la
gauche qui s'étaient retirés dès lundi
dernier mais
ça n'a pas été simple et par rapport à
tous les autres présidents de région en
particulier ceux de droite qui sont
réélus bien bien plus confortablement et
dans une clarté beaucoup plus grande car
il n'avait pas fait alliance à la
république en marche
je pense que c'est effectivement le
soulagement qui doit dominer ce soir
chez renaud muselier plus que plus que
l'euphorie comme jean luc mélenchon
d'ailleurs qui se dit soulagé de la
lourde défaite du fn en paca et se
félicite du basculement de la réunion à
gauche qui était la réunion et images
entêté jusque là dirigés par l'exécutif
l air si je ne m'abuse sur le camp
renaud muselier dit à l'instant notre
stratégie dès le départ notre stratégie
était la bonne
est-ce que c'est conforter justement
parler et pas par ce résultat ou bien
comme le là s'entendent guillaume
c'était quand même c'était quand même
très risqué pour le président sortant de
la région paca
ça a tangué alors c'est bien qu'il est
un peu délicat de se référer aux
sondages
après les deux les deux tours que nous
venons de patrick le dernier sondage de
donner à 50/50 et que la rejeter et
renaud muselier est quand même largement
vainqueur mais accordez moi la
possibilité de raisonner habillé
constants le sondage de caen il ya bien
un moment où ça un peu de tanguer les
mêmes sondages avec les méthodologies et
au moment où enfin le moment qui a été
le plus remarqué par les électeurs ce
moment où il ya eu ces discussions
d'ailleurs suscité par le premier
ministre lui-même avec la république en
rare chez sophie cluzel donc là de fait
est quelque chose qui était mouillée
mais c'est cohérent et d'ailleurs avec
l'abstention de ce soir sedan n'avaient
pas tellement envie de parler et
d'entendre parler pendant pendant cette
campagne des régionales c'était des
petits tirs des petits arrangements
entre entre entre partis pas tellement
d'ailleurs dès ce qui se passe entre les
deux tours l'aller
les électeurs trouvent ça normal
compréhensible qu'on discute qu'on
cherche à en quand on n'a pas de chance
de l'emporter à soi seul à l'emporter à
plusieurs ils n'ont pas tellement
sanctionner les les fusions les fusions
de listes alors il ya des choses qui
sont moins bien passé une région qui
détonne un peu c'est l'agression grand
test sur les alliances à gauche mais
voilà ce qui le principal message
convoyé les électeurs de la région sud
paca c'est ben non on ne veut pas être
la région qui va être de laboratoire
dans la gouvernance rassemblement
national il ya évidemment des villes et
notamment une vie des principales celle
de fréjus dans la région qui est dirigé
par le rassemblement national sur ashley
n'a été réélu triomphalement aux
municipales mais les électeurs semblent
pas vouloir que ça aille plus loin en
taille de collectivités et c'est une
sorte d'effet double lame dans la
défaite du rassemblement national parce
que il y avait ce premier tour qui a été
globalement décevant partout mais il
restait l'espoir de paca et on disait
c'était sans doute vrai que si thierry
mariani l'avait emporté mais on aurait
retenu que ça et que donc marine le pen
était en quelque sorte remise en selle
après la contre-performance de dimanche
dernier
on voit qu'il en a rien été on voit bien
que le le le
la mine grise qu'elle avait ce soir
montre que c'est un c'est vraiment un
coup dur
on va revenir sur la contre performance
de marine le pen mais d'abord revenir
sur
skali valérie pécresse d'abord après
m'excuser auprès de nos internautes pour
la mauvaise qualité de la retransmission
qui indépendantes de notre volonté
marfaing on a bien entendu la présidente
d'ile-de-france s'excuser et vous me
disiez emmanuel c'est un ton discours
qui tranche avec celui de laurent
wauquiez et dé xavier bertrand et ans je
disais tout à l'heure
s'attendant en entendant les deux
premiers en attendant la troisième on
allait avoir les prises de parole de
ceux qui prétendaient jouer un rôle pour
la campagne des présidentielles
on a entendu valérie pécresse parler
d'elle et de la région ile de france a
en fait elle a fait un discours de
présidente de région
est ce que peut-être bien il y aura
soirs d'élections régionales c'est pas
mal de temps en temps d'être à peu près
aligné à 20 quand elle parle de l'équipe
de france de la droite du centre
c'était quand même beaucoup sur la
région et notamment elle s'est projeté
avec des actions à venir pour la région
quand xavier bertrand maintenant c'est
très cohérent avec ce qu'il a toujours
dit il n'a pas caché qu'il serait
candidat présidentiel il a même
conditionné sa candidature à sa
réélection en dans les hauts de france
qui à me semble-t-il beaucoup plus parlé
sur qui la situent les outrances mula
beaucoup plus parler de lui et de la
france et l'europe qui était un petit
peu sur cette tonalité et ce sont deux
modalités de gérer ce qui commence
aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière pour les
états-majors la campagne de la
présidentielle vient de commencer
la question c'est est ce que les
français sont déjà dans la campagne des
présidentielles et veulent que ça se
passe comme ça à la campagne des
présidentielles
dès le soir du second tour des
régionales peut-être que valérie
pécresse a fait un pari qui consiste à
rester sur ce dont il est question
aujourd'hui avant de s'aventurer sur
d'autres terrains valérie pécresse c'est
prévalu donc d'une victoire contre les
extrêmes avec le soutien des
républicains sincères des deux rives je
la cite est ce que finalement quand on a
vu quand même la tonalité de la campagne
de l'entre-deux tours
on peut pas dire qu'encore une fois
varié pécresse a été un peu et lui sur
sa droite et qu'elle va gouverner sur
son centre peut-être même un peu sur sa
gauche
c'est difficile à dire en tout cas elle
a fait campagne contre la gauche ça
c'est clair
et elle n'a eu de cesse que de mettre en
garde contre une gauche qu'elle
décrivait comme étant sectaire et et
radicaliser il est en cela on le disait
à l'instant par des personnalités
éminentes de la gauche comme manuel
valls ou jugeant pollution moi je crois
qu'elle en fait ces six dernières années
valérie pécresse a à gouverner avec
beaucoup d'intelligence en fonction et
beaucoup de pragmatisme et c'est en ça
que mon avis c'est le qualificatif de
centristes qui lui convient le mieux
dans la mesure où elle est dans une
sorte d' en même temps un peu un peu
macro nist et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
rend la situation extrêmement compliquée
pour la droite dans la perspective des
présidentielles parce que vous avez un
président de région qui gouverne à
droite qui évoqué et ça marche
une présidente de région qui gouverne au
centre c'est valérie pécresse et ça
marche et un président de région qui
gouverne au peuple on va dire et c'est
xavier bertrand et ça marche aussi
alors quelle doit être la bonne
stratégie
pour l air et les assimiler pour l'année
prochaine
chacun des trois pensent que c'est la
sienne qu'est ce ça stratégique est
bonne donc à mon avis les électeurs de
droite ne sont pas sortis de l'auberge
on sait que ce camp là de deux casses
politique ne répugne jamais à
s'entredéchirer il n'est pas exclu qu'on
ait de nouveaux épisodes
je vous donne ma part dans un instant et
manuellement va faire le rappelle
justement des dernières informations des
dernières déclarations des derniers
résultats avec charlotte barrière des
bruits et des résultats notamment
également en normandie
non je vais rappeler simplement qu'au
plan national la droite arrive en tête
avec 38 1 % des voix selon les premières
estimations ifop fiducial les
républicains et leurs alliés
apparaissent donc comme la première
force politique à un an de la
présidentielle la droite est arrivé en
tête devant la gauche et europe écologie
les verts qui récoltent 34 5% des voix
au plan national suivi par le
rassemblement national avec 20 5% et la
république en marche qui comptabilise 7
% des voix
valérie pécresse vous l'avez largement
dit l'emportent largement en ile de
france selon les dernières estimations
la présidente sortante récolte 45% des
voix
valérie pécresse qui a pris la parole il
ya quelques minutes et qui a dit nous
avons relevé le défi de la crédibilité
elle a par ailleurs ajouté une équipe de
france de la droite et du centre a
émergé j'y prendrai toute ma part
valérie pécresse qui a remporté l'île de
france devant le candidat europe
ecologie les verts julien bayou qui lui
récoltent 34 % des voix
julien bayou bayou qui a affirmé par
ailleurs sur twitter je cite l'écologie
est la seule force en dynamique
john jordan bardella du rassemblement
national obtient 11% des voix en ile de
france devant le candidat en marche qui
obtient 10% des voix en auvergne
rhône-alpes laurent wauquiez est réélu
facilement avec 54% à 54 6% des voix le
président et l'air sortant de la région
l'a largement emporté lors du second
tour devant l'écologiste fabienne
grébert et le rn andré acosta rac
en paca le républicain renaud muselier
l'a emporté face à thierry mariani avec
56% des voix contre 44% des voix
thierry renaud muselier qui a qui s'est
félicité de la logique d'unité en
normandie le centriste hervé morin est
réélu haut la main à l'ex-ministre de la
défense s'est hissé en tête du second
tour avec 42 2% des voix dans les hauts
de france xavier bertrand est réélu sans
difficulté le président ex et l'air
sortant est arrivé en tête du second
tour avec plus de 54% des voix
il entame donc un deuxième mandat tout
en étant candidat pour la présidentielle
xavier bertrand qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques minutes pour dire entre autres
qu'il est allé qu'il est prêt à aller à
la rencontre de tous les français
après sa large victoire dans les hauts
de france xavier bertrand a estimé que
pour redresser notre pays il y à un
préalable le rétablissement de l'ordre
et du respect dans le grand est
jean rottner dlr est reconduit pour six
ans le président sortant a été élu pour
un deuxième mandat avec 39% des voix
lors de ce second tour des régionales en
corse l'autonomiste gilles simeoni est
réélu le président sortant s'est hissé
en tête du second tour devant le maire
excellèrent d'ajaccio et ses deux
concurrents nationaliste parmi des
prises de paroles on retiendra celle de
marine le pen qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques minutes pour dire que malgré
l'échec du rassemblement national elle
donne rendez vous aux français dès
demain pour construire tous ensemble
l'alternance dont la france a besoin le
leader de la france insoumise jean luc
mélenchon a dit quant à lui être
soulagés de la lourde défaite du
rassemblement national en paca
il s'est par ailleurs félicité du
basculement de la réunion à gauche
voilà ce que je peux vous dire pour
l'instant vincent roux merci beaucoup
charlotte quand on se retrouve dans une
demi heure pour faire un nouveau point
sur les nouveaux les autres résultats et
également les déclarations et les
réactions continuent de tomber ce soir
vous disiez justement tout à l'heure à
propos de la république en marche
il ya un phénomène que l'on observe
c'est quand elle est quant à elle est
absente et
de voir comment se répartissent et
les voies et comment justement le même
dans le sillage de ce que disait
guillaume roquette sur le positionnement
de ses présidents de droite dans les
rapports de la droite et du centre
il se trouve qu'on avait des régions la
république en marche et est éliminée dès
le premier tour faute d'avoir passé le
cap des 10% et d'avoir pu fusionner ce
sont les régions où la droite progresse
le plus nettement en auvergne
rhône-alpes 10 points de gagnés c'est
également le cas dans les hauts de
france où l'on avait ce duel droite
rassemblement national et avec la gauche
évidemment 10 points de gagner et ce
sont des régions où la gauche ne
progresse pas comme si c'est évidemment
un tout petit peu plus compliqué que ça
comme si les voies la république en
marche et est allé du côté de la droite
c'est un peu moins vrai en occitanie
c'est quand même le candidat républicain
qui a le plus semblé profiter de
l'absence de la république en marche là
où elle était présente au second tour
la république en marchant générale a
reculé alors plus court on doit avoir à
faire des lecteurs très stratège traces
très rationnel qui se sont dits meubles
pour nous c'est fini en tout cas pour le
candidat qu'on avait choisi au premier
tour y aura pas de victoire possible
comment ils se sont répartis mais sont
aussi davantage réparties semble-t-il à
droite à gauche et là où la république
en marche a le plus reculé c'est
précisément ces régions on avait un peu
dramatiser l'enjeu du fait de la
présence d'allianz à gauche avec la
france insoumise les pays de la loire et
l'île de france et dans ces deux régions
les reculs la république en marche lors
poursuit ont un peu congrue sont les
plus forts avec d'ailleurs en ile de
france plus de 3 points de moins qu'au
premier tour ce qui n'est pas le cas au
rassemblement national
alors on se rappelle qu'en 2015 le
rassemblement national avait beaucoup
reculé ça c'est pas trop le cas et
notamment pas en ile-de-france comme si
les électeurs du rassemblement national
cette fois ci c'est vraiment le noyau
dur qui s'est dit ce sera au premier et
au second tour le rassemblement national
mais pas assez nombreux aux yeux de
marine le pen en ile de france le club
un peu reculé moins que
- que moins que de la fpi va les rendre
c'est injuste il ya cinq ans je voudrais
qu'on jette un coup d'oeil quand même à
la gauche alors effectivement on a la
victoire d'huguette bello confirmé à la
réunion sur le sortant didier robert
olivier faur dit ce soir que le ps à
l'arrêt à la responsabilité de
rassembler l'ensemble de la gauche et
des écologistes
dans ce match entre la gauche les
écologistes et cette gauche radicale
nolin smith s'est ténu qui est le qui
est d'abord le vainqueur de ces
élections selon vouliez me semble que
c'est plutôt les socialistes raisonnable
si l'on en croit le très beau score de
carole delga en occitanie qui
semble-t-il est l'une des mieux élu
parmi toutes les présidents sortants
quand les gars qui avait affirmé haut et
clair qu'elle ressent plus qu'elle
refusait le le les voix de la france
insoumise et donc
quand les socialistes sont alliés
derrière les derrière les verts emmanuel
le disais tout à l'heure
le score est ce qu'on n'est pas très bon
donc cette espèce de mayonnaise d'une
union de la gauche qui serait plus plus
plus du couleurs plus vives
ça ne fonctionne pas très bien et c'est
sans doute parce que entre la france
insoumise et et des écologistes
un peu radicaux dont les socialistes ne
savent que de force d'appoint
les électeurs ils font pas forcément la
différence et du coup il n'y a pas de
il n'ya pas d'élan qui se pose parce
qu'il ya une concurrence qui est qui et
qui est trop forte donc encore une fois
le socialisme du gouvernement on va dire
s'en sort bien
les socialistes raisonnable ce qui ce
qui était les présidents sortants on
peut aussi penser à celui de l'aquitaine
par exemple dans la roue s'est
effectivement et et de marie-guite dufay
en bourgogne franche comté françois
goneau dans le centre-ville de noir et
loïg chesnais-girard qui était le
candidat socialiste qui s'était présenté
contre la vie d'ailleurs de jean yves le
drian en bretagne
absolument même si jean yves le drian
avait dit au départ je vais refuser de
choisir entre les deux pendant la
campagne en disant j'ai deux enfants
l'un est socialiste l'autre élève
c'était une image évidemment la
physiologique et l'autre était la
république en marche sera ben oui et tu
voulais pas choisir entre les deux donc
c'est une ces questions c'est qu'il n'y
a pas deux il n'y a pas de dynamique et
c'est une un contraste assez fort avec
ce qui s'est passé aux municipales
souvenez vous avec les villes que manuel
rappelé tout à l'heure avec bordeaux
avec strasbourg avec marseille là pour
le coup on dit ça y est il s'est passé
quelque chose
hélas le laissait n'a pas été transformé
c'est encore une fois étonnant 7,7
ces élections régionales c'est un petit
peu comme un retour dans le passé avant
avant en marche qui bouleversé toute la
vie politique française
avant le l'inquiétude sur le climat qui
qui qui mettait les idées écologistes
dans présence forte dans l'opinion des
français et avant un rassemblement
national dont on disait doute on dit
d'ailleurs au toujours que la présidente
pourrait être et lieu à la tête de
l'état c'est un peu un petit une petite
séquence nostalgie au revival
ça rappelle qu'il ya un petit effet de
prisme déformant des municipales c'est
qu'aux municipales on s'intéresse aux
grandes villes toulouse avait raison le
terreau de cette suprématie de l'allier
de ce dynamique écologique c'est
beaucoup dans les denrées alors c'est
pas rien les grandes villes il n'y a pas
là vraiment c'est habiterait l'accordé
pas le dominique reynié qui dit
finalement les écologistes n'ont pas du
tout des élections bah ils ont gagné ils
ont montré des dynamiques qui leur
permettaient encore une fois là où les
socialistes n'étaient pas sortant de
virer en tête mais c'est vrai que là il
ya une forme contre-performance qui
s'est heurtée à la prime aux sortants et
je pense à la gestion de valérie
pécresse et que la région hyper
urbanisées et la région ile de france
n'a pas permis cette percée est fait est
que la vence de julien bayou sur ses
deux futurs colistière au premier tour
n'était pas très spectaculaire par
rapport au bassin encore présents qu'il
de france pour l'électorat écologiste
oui ça quand même une signification
nationale aussi c'est quand même c'est
le patron du parti julien bayou donc
certes le ile de france n'est pas là
n'est pas le pays tout entier
mais le mot confusion et que ça ne crée
pas une dynamique en faveur de son parti
et de la façon dont il le dirige
ils ont ils ont fait quand même pas loin
de 30 6% des voix c'est un petit peu
plus quand même supérieur un petit peu
là l'addition des listes qui
l'addition de leurs c'est vrai mais mais
mais face à eux
valérie pécresse a davantage progressé
donc c'est la dynamique elle était
apparemment pas de leur côté
acorn la tribu l'a d'ailleurs la forte
progression de valérie pécresse
entre les deux tours il ya plusieurs
phénomènes qu'ils expliquent entre
autres le recul d'un point donc moins
fort qu'en 2000 en 2015 du rassemblement
national jordan bardella le recul de
revenir dans le rang saint martin qui
perd qui perd deux points
et puis cette logique qui semble
s'appliquer à peu près partout
droite ou gauche pour les sortants
arrivé en tête au soir du premier tour
on va au secours de la victoire
heureusement qu'il ya la réunion alors
on voit ce que ça donne dans les autres
territoires d'outre-mer pour avoir une
région qui changent de couleur pour
donner le sentiment que ces élections
reproduit quelque part quelque chose
d'un peu différent du scrutin précédent
et la gauche de retour au conseil
régional d'ile-de-france dit karima
delli sera là pour lutter et durée pour
prendre quelque chose que vous disiez
justement sur les trois offres que
représentent les présidents d'autres
france d'ile-de-france et de région
rhône alpes il faut prendre également
renaud muselier puisque quand même pas
casse est une région extrêmement
importante
il y a finalement deux stratégies ce
soir il ya la stratégie également
d'alliance avec la république en marche
et puis il ya la stratégie du refus
avait ajouté de la complexité également
pour les électeurs de droite
c'est vrai mais
la situation de renaud muselier est
assez spécifique d'abord parce qu'il
n'est pas candidat déclaré à l'élection
présidentielle et il n'est pas
improbable qu'ils fassent partie des
favoris en tout cas à ce stade
et puis l'autre élément c'est que le
cette alliance avec en marche
elle fonctionne que par ce qu'on
remarque n'existe pas au niveau
au niveau des collectivités locales et
donc ça s'est fait assez naturellement
dès le premier tour
parce qu'encore une fois en marche sans
macron c'est que c'est ce ça n'a pas de
consistance aujourd'hui en tout cas
auprès auprès des électeurs dès lors que
emmanuel macron c'est plausible souhaite
se présenter pour un second mandat
la situation est complètement
bouleversée et là pour le coup une
stratégie à la muselier elle n'a pas de
sens ou alors c'est celle que
probablement même certainement suivront
tous les gens délais requis sont déjà
passés à en marche
qu'il s'agisse des premiers ministres
bruno le maire ou de houe de gérald
darmanin
il y à un autre un autre phénomène aussi
qui peut qui peut jouer si on suit cette
cette thématique c'est que finalement
est-ce que emmanuel macron malgré le
fait que la république en marche et
essuyez les chèques qu'elle a essuyé ce
soir à la suite des municipales est-ce
que malgré de cela il ne peut pas tirer
profit de la division à la tête des
républicains et de la droite est
finalement être le candidat de la droite
oui c'est vrai que c'est une lecture
conte qu'on peut faire et quand je
voyais tout à l'heure en régie laurent
wauquiez commencé son intervention avant
même que xavier bertrand déterminer la
sienne pour pour se satisfaire se
félicité de ces résultats le disais que
ça va être compliqué le jeu à droite
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
emmanuel macron je ne sais pas moi je
pense que la politique c'est d'abord des
dynamiques et la dynamique qu'il n'y en
a pas pour en marche encore une fois
c'est pas forcément gênant parce que je
pense que cette élection est une sorte
de parenthèse c'est à dire que c'est
avant toute chose un retour non c'est un
retour à un monde ancien non c'est un
retour au monde ancien dans la gestion
des régions et probablement des
départements mais parce que les français
font vraiment clairement la différence
et le le dégagisme est un mouvement qui
a été fatal aux dirigeants nationaux on
l'a bien vu lors des précédentes
élections présidentielles mais ça neuf
ça ne fonctionne pas dans les élections
locales parce que en gros les français
voient en tout cas pour ceux qui ceux
qui veulent bien les voter il voit un
peu les bilans et voient ce qui a été
fait et ils n'ont pas envie de 2,2
d'effacer l'ardoisé tous les tous les
cinq ans comme à l'élection
présidentielle donc je pense pas qu'on
puisse en tirer vraiment de
d'enseignement national
si on essaie de se projeter sur l'année
prochaine rappelons-nous quels étaient
les quatre forces dominantes et
personnalités dominantes de la
présidentielle de 2007 s'était emmanuel
macron marine le pen au second tour mais
aussi très très peu de place derrière en
tout cas très peu de points de
pourcentage derrière françois fillon et
jeu
jean luc mélenchon françois fillon c'est
ce qu'ils étaient devenus de ses
ambitions politiques
pour les trois autres c'est une mauvaise
soirée ces deux soirées du vin et du 27
sont nés quand même dans une espèce de
reflux de ces propositions de rupture
que ces trois là un carnet et ce qui
amène aussi à réfléchir c'est que le
reflux des propositions de rupture
on les voit un peu partout en europe sur
la séquence des cinq dernières années
you keep en grande bretagne parce qu'il
a atteint son objet ils ont eu leur exit
mais ciudadanos et podemos en espagne
regardez l'espagne parce que c'est la
boxe quand même qu'il ya vox qui monte
mais celles qui ont été effectivement
sur les propositions proches des manuels
macron et proche de jean luc mélenchon
dans ce par ce pays qui était aussi le
pays phare du bipartisme entre le psg et
le partido popular il ya le recul de ces
forces là donc c'est ce qui reste à
emmanuel macron c'est qu'il est
président de la république et qu'il est
bien positionné dans les sondages pense
pas que vous m'aviez indiqué pour may
est invité pour systématiquement prendre
des grandes distances avec ce que disent
les sondages mais ça parce que pourtant
ce que je vais faire là c'est pas
suffisant
donc il reste d'être président de la
république est d'avoir gagné les
européennes ça c'est quelques c'est pas
rien les européennes finalement c'est
une sélection la clé on aura le plus
participé dans le cycle des élections
intermédiaires et donc c'est ça qui doit
être un peu leur père mais attention
pardon je vous coupe mais le les
européennes je prends par exemple les
européennes de 2009 où le parti de
nicolas sarkozy arrive en tête ça ne
permet pas à nicolas sarkozy de
l'emporter en 2012 vient de dire une
bêtise il n'a pas gagné les européennes
il était second juste derrière loin
derrière les républicains qui avaient
moins devant l'elysée eux la
contre-performance européen oui monsieur
ce qui me
me frappe alors peut-être que il ya une
nouvelle donne qui était en train
d'infuser dans l'opinion et que ce n'est
pas encore le cas mais c'est ce sondage
qui a été publié cette semaine ses deux
confrères de challenges et qui montrait
que pour le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle la donne n'était pas
bouleversé c'est à dire que c'est pas
parce que les français ont très peu voté
pour les candidats de la république en
marche et du rassemblement national pour
ces élections régionales qu'ils ont
changé pour autant leur ticket gagnant
pour l'élection présidentielle
alors ça peut changer encore une fois
peut-être que là pour le coup
manuel qui peut le dire parce que
l'opinion mais un certain temps avant
d'avant de 2,2 d'évoluer mais il ya ce
point là qui fait qu'à mon avis ya pas
eu de bouleversement
et puis le second point un kit est
essentielle pour la droite c'est
qu'elles sont ces éléments de
différenciation d'avec emmanuel macron
cette question se posait avant
l'élection régionale je ne vois pas en
quoi elle ne se pose plus à partir de
demain matin et a fortiori avec ce que
dit emmanuel en rappelant justement la
performance de la république en marche
aux élections européennes de 2009 2010 9
pardon ou le phénomène majeur avait été
la captation de l'électorat de droite
par par la république en marche
autrement dit et c'est par exemple
analyse que c'est lundi dernier jérôme
sainte marie da qui était de dire il
n'ya plus effectivement si on avait
cette discussion sur le bloc contre bloc
qui la thèse de de son livre il ya un
phénomène un changement c'est à
l'intérieur de ce qu'il appelle le bloc
élitaire
le bloc des élites contre le bugue bloc
populaire qui va prendre le lead danse
dans ce bloc élitaire moi il ya un autre
truc il ya une autre phénomène qui nous
fasse et qui me frappe
on en a parlé tout à l'heure c'était
donc le discours à la fois de xavier
bertrand est à la fois nous laurent
wauquiez effectivement ils se sont
marchés ap un peu tirés la bourre sur
sur la prise de parole mais surtout sur
les thématiques thématique très
localistes très territoire c'est laurent
wauquiez très social chez xavier chez
xavier bertrand est ce que il n'ya pas
malgré la contre-performance du
rassemblement national malgré la
contre-performance des partis populistes
en europe des partis contestataires pour
reprendre la terminologie de la fondapol
et craignait est-ce que par contre on
peut pas reprendre la thèse de notre ami
alexandre ii vecchio dans son dernier
livre composition la thématique
populiste elle continue d'infuser toute
façon c'est on le sait bien que c'est la
clé pour la droite il faut qu'elle aille
au peuple si elle veut l'emporter
oui alors ce qui est frappant d'ailleurs
c'est que là aussi on va avoir un
quelque chose là la fois très simple
puisque finalement il ya volonté
manifestée par tout le monde de se
reconnecter avec cette partie des
français qui ne s'intéressent plus à la
politique qui ne croient plus à la
politique qui se sentent abandonnés
qu'ils se sentent négligés voire méprisé
mais avec une telle unanimité que ça
pose un autre problème qu'elle celui
d'un sentiment d'indifférenciation alors
j'ai pas que laurent wauquiez et xavier
bertrand ont fait le discours qu'aurait
pu faire s'il avait été candidat déclaré
à la présidentielle carole delga ou
alain rousset y avait des thématiques
spécifiques sur le communautarisme les
télés l'assistanat on entendrait
évidemment pas un candidat de gauche
dénoncé l' assistanat quand on l'a fait
xavier bertrand est ce qu'à dire comme
l'a fait pendant laurent wauquiez est ce
qu a dit xavier bertrand en disant je ne
permettrai pas que l'homme
dénigrent la france on voit aussi en
quoi ça fait écho mais les élections ça
a toujours été un peu s'adresser une
espèce de base électorale
une forme de clientèle électorale
identifier et là tout le monde veut
parler au même jeu bien qu'ils étaient
horribles qui luttèrent contre bloc
populaire sauf que les élites si on les
définit rigoureusement c'est très très
bonne d'électeurs et que c'est qu'en
fait un bloc auquel personne ne
s'identifie on a entendu personne je
crois depuis très longtemps dire moi mon
moi je vais faire campagne pour les gens
aisés
les gens qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent
et finalement les premiers de cordée je
crois que c'est une expression qu'on
n'entendra plus jamais donc ça va être
un risque aussi de confusion où
finalement à force que tout le monde
veuille défendre les petits les sans
grades
on a l'impression que à nouveau le
discours politique c'est un discours
indistinct et indifférenciée c'est vrai
mais c'est aussi peut-être une piste de
renouvellement de l'offre politique de
la droite c'est intéressant pour rester
sur ces trois de ces trois leaders
valérie pécresse laurent wauquiez xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse est sur une
ligne assez traditionnel de centre droit
elle rend hommage ce soir au président
du sénat gérard larcher qui est
l'incarnation de cet équilibre quand
laurent wauquiez n'a laissé que très peu
d'oxygène au rassemblement national avec
une campagne effectivement sur des
thèmes de sécurité de refus de
l'assistanat 2 2 ce qui est une des
dimensions du vote et rennes et le
xavier bertrand lui il se positionne
plutôt sur la dîme la dimension sociale
du vote rassemblement national faut pas
oublier que
c'est un homme qui a voté contre le
traité de maastricht sont pas si
nombreux à droite pendant tout son
mandat dès qu'il y avait une usine qui
ferme et dans sa région il était au
premier rang de des manifestations aux
côtés de la cgt contre un patronat qui
ignoraient les réalités sociales
donc on voit des stratégies qui sont
différentes en fait entre valérie
pécresse qui dit bon moi je ne dévie pas
de ma ligne
le on sait ce que la droite gagne quand
elle quand elle est plutôt raisonnable
et un terrain laurent wauquiez qui est
plus raide sur les sujets régaliens et
un avis bertrand plus sociale et pour
l'instant on voit pas ce qui peut
l'emporter de façon déterminante parce
que les cartes ne sont pas encore abattu
loin de là et les électeurs probablement
ne sont pas encore projeté dans
l'élection présidentielle vraiment
d'ailleurs frappant dans ce que rappelle
guillaume à l'instant c'est que c'est
très imprégné par les territoires dont
ils sont élus en tout cas je vous aviez
bertrand et valérie pécresse
cette île de france très urbanisé très
évidemment avec une dynamique économique
et territorial avec une mixité à la fois
social et d'origine qui est une réalité
incontestable dans ce territoire et
xavier bertrand qui est lui dans cette
terre où et ça ça se voit finalement
beaucoup plus aux élections cantonales
pardon départementale dans l'analyse du
premier tour que aux élections
régionales où le rassemblement national
a reculé il ya des vrais
contre-performance dans les cantons du
pas de calais notamment qu'une zone de
fort du rassemblement national
là où dans le vaucluse qui est une autre
zone de force alors c'est toujours cette
opposition entre le rassemblement
national du nord et le rassemblement
national du sud allait plus que jamais
vrai cette opposition est ce contraste
justement on ad on a des premières
indications la des premières tendances
sur les élections départementales est un
peu frustrant c'est que effectivement
les choses remontent beaucoup plus
facilement sur les régionales on a déjà
l'histoire que sur les départementales
il est assez vraisemblable que
l'histoire soit un peu la même et que
là où ce qui avait marqué les
départementales de 2015 était la
performance au premier tour du
rassemblement national et son incapacité
à faire basculer un département attend
dès lors plus à l'est voient la laine
dont on parlait aussi là alors je parle
et je tiens à ce que soit prouvée un
autre sans connaître les résultats dans
les départements mais déjà au soir du
premier tour on faisait une analyse que
le rennais l'à-peu-près 0 chances de
faire basculer des départements la
question pour laquelle je n'ai pas la
réponse à l'heure qu'il est c'est est ce
qu'il pourra garder la trentaine de
cantons donc la soixantaine d'élus qui
l'avait qui l'a vue puis décroché il y
en a plusieurs qui était qui semblait
sérieusement compromis dans la halle
dans la reconduction ça on fera le bilan
plutôt demain alors effectivement vous
avez commencé à voir d'ailleurs les
résultats sur les départementales sur le
site du figaro juste en dessous de ce
player vous avez également l'éditorial
d'alexis braisé qui vient d'être publié
que vous allez pouvoir également
retrouver et puis on va pouvoir faire
également un point sur les dernières
déclarations les nouvelles déclarations
les nouveaux résultats qui s'affine
d'heure en heure mais qui confirme en
tout cas la tendance qu'on avait observé
au 1er tour la victoire des sortants ont
fait le point avec vous charles barion
oui et oui selon les dernières
estimations il faut que fiducial la
droite arrive en tête avec 38% 38,1 pour
cent des voix à l'échelle nationale la
droite est arrivé en tête devant la
gauche et europe écologie et verts qui
récoltent 34 8% des voix suivi par le
rassemblement national avec 20 2% des
voix
la république en marche comptabilise
quant à elle 6 9% des voix à l'échelle
nationale en ile-de-france valérie
pécresse est largement réélu avec 45%
des voix la présidente excellèrent
sortante devant les devancent
l'écologiste julien bayou à la tête
d'une liste d'union de gauche qui
termine en deuxième position avec 34 %
des voix
valérie pécresse qui s'est exprimé tout
à l'heure a affirmé je cite une équipe
de france de la droite et du centre a
émergé j'y prendrai toute ma part at
elle dit julien bayou s'est quant à lui
exprimé sur twitter pour dit
l'écologie est la seule force en
dynamique en auvergne et rhône-alpes
laurent wauquiez est réélu facilement
avec 54 6% des voix en paca le
républicain renaud muselier dlr l'a
emporté face à thierry mariani des est
reine du r n avec 56% des voix contre
44%
renaud muselier s'est félicitée la
logique d'unité a gagné at il dit en
normandie le centriste hervé morin est
réélu haut la main l'ex ministre de la
défense s'est hissé en tête du second
tour avec 42,2 % des voix dans les hauts
de france xavier bertrand est réélu sans
difficulté le président ex et l'air
sortant est arrivé en tête du second
tour avec plus de 54% des voix après sa
large victoire dans les hauts de france
xavier bertrand a estimé que pour
redresser notre pays il y à un préalable
leur attendent le rad le rétablissement
de l'ordre et du respect en nouvelles
aquitaine alain rousset est réélu pour
un cinquième mandat avec 39 2% des voix
le président socialiste sortant est
arrivé en tête à l'issue du second tour
devant la candidate et rennes
edwige diaz en occitanie carole delga
est réélu face aux arènes avec 58 5% des
voix la présidente socialiste sortante
permet à la gauche de garder l'une de
ces terres existe une de ses terres
historiques en bretagne loïg
chesnais-girard du parti socialiste
conserve la région le président
socialiste sortant n'est cependant pas
certain de parvenir à obtenir la
majorité au conseil régional et pourrait
devoir faire face à un troisième tour
dans le grand est
jean rottner est reconduit pour six ans
le président et l'air sortant a été élu
pour un deuxième mandat avec 39% des
voix encore l'autonomie
l'autonomiste gilles simeoni est réélu
le président sortant s'est hissé en tête
du second tour devant le maire
excellèrent d'ajaccio et ses deux
concurrents nationaliste parmi les
prises de parole
on retiendra celle de marine le pen qui
s'est exprimé il ya quelques minutes
pour dire que malgré l'échec du
rassemblement national
elle donne rendez vous aux français dès
demain pour construire tous ensemble
l'alternance dont la france a besoin
le leader de la france insoumise a quant
à lui dit
c'est dit pardon soulagé de la lourde
défaite du rassemblement national en
paca sont les propos de jean luc
mélenchon que je n'ai pas cité donc
c'est bien le leader de la france
insoumise pardon il s'est félicité jean
luc mélenchon par ailleurs du
basculement de la réunion à gauche la
droite a en effet perdu la réunion la
candidate
une quête bello soutenue par la france
insoumise et le parti socialiste a
vaincu le président ex et l'air sortant
didier robert à la tête de l'île de la
réunion depuis 2010 voilà vingt sans
merci
charlotte et on fera un dernier tour
d'horizon dans un peu moins d'une demi
heure avant de rejoindre nos partenaires
de la chaîne parlementaire et de public
sénat on est heureux d'être avec vous on
continue de répondre on n'a pas
tellement fait on va le refaire à vos
questions à vos commentaires il y avait
justement un commentaire d'un internaute
qui dit que marine le pen doit
démissionner ce soir du rassemblement
national
on imagine qui effectivement c'est ce
qu'on disait depuis le début de la
soirée l'ambiance à perpignan pour le
congrès du rassemblement national la
semaine prochaine risque d'être houleuse
mais cet instant est ce que le
rassemblement national est en mesure
d'avoir un meilleur candidat que marine
le pen oui et si marine le pen
démissionne emmanuel macron aussi or les
deux hypothèses vous paraissent aussi
peu probable l'une que l'autre
maintenant la question qui se pose est
honnêtement elle est compliqué c'est de
savoir est-ce que
le restauration elle a fait une contre
performance en particulier par rapport à
ce qu'annonçaient les sondages parce que
il ya eu il la prime aux sortants ne se
sont mobilisés que les gens qui étaient
d'accord et qu'il voulait valider le les
exécutifs sortants ou est ce que c'est
pour des raisons d'une politique
nationale c'est à dire ce qu'on a appelé
la dédiabolisation est-ce que l'offre
politique que que qu'incarne marine le
pen n'est plus
ne rencontre plus le autant de décocher
les français qu'on a pu le voir dans le
passé c'est le point de vue de son père
jean marie le pen qui l'a dit
publiquement et un gentil ça n'intéresse
personne exactement et c'est
probablement de sa dent ils vont parler
à perpignan cette semaine moi je pense
qu'il faut être très prudent parce que
parce que c'est très difficile de de
comprendre pourquoi les gens sont pas
allés voter puisque par définition on ne
sait pas quelles sont leurs convictions
je pense pas que ça ait joué il me
semble que le les les questions
sécuritaires les questions de
délinquance était extrêmement présente
dans les préoccupations des électeurs
ces dernières semaines à cause d'eux des
événements dramatiques et violent qu'on
a pu connaître et que les les candidats
durera sûrement nationale étaient les
plus offensifs sur ce sujet de façon
assez classique donc ça aurait pu
marcher
donc je crois que c'est moins un
problème de décalage d'offre globale que
d'un désintérêt des électeurs
encore une fois pour cette élection que
monte la tension mais ça n'est qu'une
pure hypothèse que j'ai aucun élément
tangible pour pour prouver ce que
j'avance mais c'était un point de vue ça
ne vous entendra pas quand vous qu'on
vous demande le vôtre mon cher guillaume
et maintenant je suis presque tentés là
nous faire mutuellement un peu de
publicité
il se trouve que week-end prochain dans
le figaro magazine se trouvera le
baromètre politique mensuel n'en parle
pas beaucoup et je le ferai avec plaisir
et c'est vrai que là on aura un peu le
verdict parce que on a à peu près
toujours eu la trace dans ce baromètre
suivant les élections de l'impact réel
car déjà eu un peu le temps de mon avis
de se produire sur ses principaux
leaders sur emmanuel macron alors ça
depuis toujours en sa faveur
effectivement on en mal d'aidés
européennes ce qui permettait de dire un
peu fou cement qui les avaient qui les
avait gagné on verra ce qu'il en est
tout cela et ce sera un élément un
élément important pas que j'ai une envie
particulière d'aller au secours de
marine le pen mais le score de
rassemblement national à ces élections
régionales et départementales basse et
ça reste le deuxième meilleur score de
toute les longues
histoire du rassemblement national et
c'est aussi ça un peu le problème c'est
la longue histoire du rassemblement
national
on n'a d'équivalent nulle part d'un
parti qui finalement évolué dans les
mêmes eaux depuis si longtemps
quarante ans d'histoire politique entre
15 et 25% deux dirigeants un seul
patronyme le pen il ya peut-être aussi
un effet de lassitude
au delà de la banalisation par en gros
limoux semant des thèmes les plus
saillants de l'agressivité ou de la
provocation le fait est que si marine le
pen a porté son parti au niveau où elle
a porté entre 2010 et on va dire 2015
c'est parce que il y avait pu ce qui
était considéré par certains comme les
ou tranche de son père c'est vraiment ce
que nous y est les gens émus elle est
beaucoup moins provocante elle est
beaucoup moins clivante que son père
mais problème c'est que voilà il ya
peut-être aussi un effet de lassitude et
les gens qui cherchent une offre
politique en rupture trouve peut-être
que celle light un peu trop installé un
paysage jean-paul nos demandes
moi je m'interroge comment l air peuvent
faire évoluer son discours le même
depuis toujours s'enlaçant la croissance
économique
qui profitera de la croissance
économique peut-être qu'il profitera de
la côte de la croix de la rode mise
puisque la reprise semble la même s'il
est quand même plus probable que ce soit
emmanuel macron qui en profitent
puisqu'il devrait logiquement en être
crédité pour autant c'est ce qu'indique
pardon je vous coupe mais c'est ce
qu'indique puisque on en parlait tout à
l'heure le dernier indicateur de dari
cinq teintes interactive où on voit que
emmanuel macron profite en tout les cas
de la sortie du confinement
c'est vrai alors on est très prudents
les uns et les autres depuis depuis
quelques jours sur les sondages et leur
portée réelle mais c'est vrai que les
français sont satisfaits de ce
déconfinement et que cette satisfaction
et à juste titre c'est super vraiment
c'est emmanuel macron qui le créditent
de ceux des confinement qui a été plutôt
bien géré moi je ne pense pas que la
droite doit faire campagne sur la
croissance économique et sur sur la
façon dont il entend gérer le pays
franchement quand bruno le maire
ministre des finances je vois pas ce que
la droite serait différent de ce qui est
fait actuellement par amar nathan qui le
lie l'ifrap a dressé un bilan des trois
dernier quinquennat le moins mauvais
était celui de hollande est le plus à
droite aussi
alors ça c'était parce qu'effectivement
les peut-être que les notamment les
stocks de compétitivité les charges des
entreprises avaient été durablement mais
sinon moi ce que je pense c'est que il
faut que la droite revienne elle même
c'est à dire que l n'ai pas honte de
prendre des positions fortes en
particulier sur ce sujet de
l'immigration qui dont on dont on sait
que c'est vraiment celui sur lequel pour
l'instant emmanuel macron ne bouge pas
bien sûr que la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine mais les 280
mille personnes qui rentrent également
chaque année sa a priori on les remet
pas en cause et une grande majorité de
français se ce saut pose à ce que ce que
ce flux continue comme aujourd'hui
à mon avis c'est sur des thèmes comme
cela plutôt que sur la promesse de mieux
gérer le pays de toute façon quand on a
atteint des niveaux de dettes aussi
stratosphérique que celui de la france
il faudra un demi-siècle avant de
revenir à quelque chose de raisonnable
donc ça me paraît pas le meilleur levier
pour gagner une élection présidentielle
dans moins d'un an
autrement dit la question c'est de
savoir si finalement un parti un peu
plus à droite
en tout cas une droite qui soit un peu
plus à droite qui se droitise et qui se
popularise qui joue la carte du peuple
peut l'emporter et peu
sur cette thématique là ou pas oui mais
dans une réflexion effectivement qui
doit être bas lesquels sont confrontés
tous les partis mais il ya des questions
qui se posent spécifiquement je pense à
la droite je crois que c'est laurent
wauquiez qui m'était très fortement en
avant le thème des relocalisations
a priori c'est pas les socialistes qu'on
délocalise et c'est peut-être la
politique d'un certain nombre de
dirigeants qui ont incité des
entreprises à faire des choix d'aller
chercher des modèles productifs de la
main d'oeuvre des modèles économiques
qui consistait à faire à faire produire
ailleurs mais c'est un peu la question
qui est posée c'est salut du modèle
économique finalement relocaliser c'est
soit on rend les conditions plus
attractives
ce qui était quand même effectif on en
parlait à l'instant le pari de françois
hollande est aussi des manuels macron
mais il ya quelque chose de ce très
raisonnable qui vient d'être appelé
c'est que en agissant sur ces leviers là
on met des décennies à résoudre les
problèmes et c'est là d'ailleurs un des
dangers qui guettent la politique en ce
moment c'est quand on est sur des
discours qui sont extrêmement court
termiste dans l'échéance de la promesse
qu on court le risque de décevoir je
pense que les français sont assez
raisonnables pour comprendre que des
choses qui peuvent pas se résoudre en un
claquement de doigts donc peuvent
l'accepter mais bien sûr mais évidemment
c'est tout le problème est là d'ailleurs
c'est le décalage entre et ça a été
renforcée par le quinquennat entre la
nécessité de dire qu'on va résoudre les
problèmes en cinq ans et la nature des
problèmes qu'il s'agit de résoudre où il
faut je pense sur un certains d'entre
eux peut-être que j'aurai un peu de
moreau ici ce soir mais toi ma
connaissance de la manière dont les
français aiment être impliqué dans les
choix politiques intéressés à aux enjeux
et aux mécanismes me permet permet de
faire en sorte qu'ils admettent qu un
certain nombre de solutions vont pas
être trouvée du jour au lendemain
laurent wauquiez parler d'euro kolda
localisation mais effectivement pour que
est alors à moins de mettre un pistolet
sur la tente la tempe pardon des patrons
pour qui réinstalle des usines en france
mais sinon il ya qu'il ya que deux de
façon de les obtenir ces relocalisations
un effectivement emmanuel le disait c2c
de faire baisser le niveau des charges
pour que les entreprises françaises
soient à nouveau compétitive quand elles
produisent en france ou bien c'est d'une
manière ou d'une autre de fermer les
frontières c'est à dire de revenir sur
le libre échange qui est la règle
aujourd'hui et est ce que ce serait plus
favorable à la france les français sont
pas du tout décidé là dessus alors ça
peut se faire sur des sujets spécifiques
on se souvient d'ailleurs de laurent
wauquiez qui avait déclenché une
polémique en prenant la préférence
régionale pour les marchés publics de
deux revers grenade alors même que
c'était théoriquement interdite par les
règles des appels d'offres mais ça peut
être valable comme ça sur des points
spécifiques mais sinon pour le reste est
ce qu'on va aller dire à nos amis
l'union européenne va finalement
peut-être revenir sur sur la règle de
libre circulation des marchandises à
l'intérieur de l'union est ce qu'on va
aller voir les chinois les américains en
disant on va peut-être négocier les
accords du gatt ou de l'om sait plus
exactement ça va pas être simple
donc je pense que c'est par là dessus
que que les républicains peuvent espérer
l'emporter il ya une autre chose peut
être qu'on n'a pas peut-être pas assez
souligné enfin dites moi si je vous aime
à l'interprétation j'ai trouvé que la
tonalité
delà du discours de l'allocution de
renaud muselier était à serrer entre
guillemets régionaliste et il a beaucoup
parlé de la région il a envoyé un signal
à l'europe en disant que la région était
attractive et finalement il a dit on
reste de la nation je vous dis
simplement qu'on est libre et qu'on
rebelles
donc comment vous interpréter ça pour le
coup je pense que c'était des discours
de président de région réélu celui qui
était le plus le plus régionale mais
c'est aussi comme ça qu'il avait posé la
tonalité de sa campagne et c'est un peu
dans le prolongement de ce sur quoi il a
voulu mettre l'enjeu aussi parce que
dire que une région peut être soit comme
avant gouverné par les républicains soit
être la région qui aurait été prise par
le rassemblement national
ça représentait un enjeu sur tout un tas
de deux dimensions que je pense renaud
muselier ne pouvait pas ignorer un des
enjeux des régions notamment dans leurs
compétences économiques
c'est devenir des territoires de
rayonnement d'attractivité et notamment
à l'échelle à l'échelle européenne
c'est aussi un peu l'ambition d'ailleurs
de créer des grandes régions là où il
était trop petit et je pense que enfin
sans vouloir prétendre savoir ce qu'il
avait en tête au moment où il est soumis
tout ça je pense que c'est aussi un des
enjeux qu'il pouvait penser être celui
de ces élections de ne pas plomber
l'attractivité ce territoire en en
faisant ce territoire ce coin de la
france où le rassemblement national lors
être emporté parce qu'il se trouve que
vu d'extérieur vu de l'extérieur les
investisseurs les autres pays européens
pas une grande image de rassemblement
national donc c'était un élément
d'attractivité corps était un peu
embêtant oui et puis les investisseurs
le monde culturel aussi paca
c'est le festival de cannes pour pour
beaucoup de gens c'est une région
extraordinairement touristique lui
d'accord quand vous allez sur les
pontons et des ports de pâques à vous
voyez pas beaucoup de drapeaux français
sur les bateaux dans un an on signale
que peut-être tiré mariani qui est donc
le l'un des grands vaincus de la soirée
devrait prendre la parole
au pontet qui le qg de sa campagne
peut-être qu'on l'aura avant la fin de
ce te de ce premier plateau donc
deux soirées électorales un autre un
autre point qui mérite peut-être
d'autres
souligner et effectivement c'est là la
situation un peu particulière de ces
régions comme le grand est la bretagne
et où la corse qui également reconduit
des présidents sortants je pense
notamment à la corse avec effectivement
la prime aux régionalistes
gilles simeoni là c'est un phénomène qui
est un petit peu différent la corse
parce que on a obtenu on a on a observé
quand même une participation qui est
plus forte que sur le continent et qui
est lié un peu également au destin de
nul au dessin du statut de ces
collectivités locales qui vont actionne
pas du tout comme les les autres régions
qui est pas subdivisée en département
l'ours avait été d'ailleurs une des
grandes surprises de l'élection de 2015
cette victoire des listes régionalistes
et autonomistes en corse et de fait on a
renouvelé la quelque chose quand on
avait vu au premier tour c'est à dire
que les corses sont sentis concernés
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est ce serait
intéressant de ne pas faire de l'île de
beauté en cette échéance une espèce de
particularisme quelque chose à part
c'est sûr que d'un point de vue
institutionnel et du comportement et de
l'offre politique c'est ta part mais la
raison pour laquelle les corses se sont
dit tiens il ya de l'enjeu
il ya quelque chose qui se joue ça nous
touche et ça nous intéresse c'est
peut-être une source d'inspiration aussi
pour faire en sorte que dans les autres
régions
on se disent la même chose et donc à une
réflexion à avoir
on l'a déjà évoqué sur le modèle
décentralisateur en france et le modèle
d'organisation des collectivités
territoriales parce qu'effectivement
vous le disiez la cette collectivité
régionale corse
elle est très spécifique et elle a
beaucoup de pouvoir et beaucoup de
responsabilités ça veut dire que l a un
impact très concret dans la vie des gens
et on peut comprendre que
du coup la participation était plus
élevé parce qu'encore une fois je pense
que c'était ça le point-clé ceux qui
sont allés voter
c'est ce qu'ils disent eh ben oui ma
région elle est bien gérée l'été arrive
à l'heure les lycées sont bien
entretenus et donc je vais aller
conforter le l'exécutif sortant est
encore sous le nom portance de la région
et de de la collectivité régionale
efforts sur la vie concrète des gens ils
se sont encore plus dérangé pour dire là
aussi ben oui on continue comme ça
un dernier peut-être un autre point qui
est soulignée par les internautes qui en
la maintenant débattent sur la dette des
balades sur les biens fonciers de la
dépense ou de l'avenant dépenses
publiques enfin moi rien n'a pas trop
qui plébiscitent la dépense publique
je reconnais bien là des internautes de
figaro live sur la question une autre
une autre question qui est posée clament
qu'ils aient qui interroge c'est quand
je vois par exemple qu'alain rousset qui
en a qui ont donc en poste depuis 1998
et quand il continue à être dirigé cet
exécutif régional est ce que il n'ya pas
justement une question qui est posée au
niveau de la décentralisation
c'est à dire qu'il ya un côté un peu
quand même un peu un peu hors sol
surtout avec des supers région à
nouvelle aquitaine et les grandes comme
comme l'autriche est ce que est ce
qu'ils s'étaient intervenante point de
vue cette semaine qui posait la question
est ce que il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
quelque part et et à travers le laps
tension massive
un échec de la décentralisation dans
l'articulation en tout cas entre
l'élection régionale comme étant moyens
d'arbitrer le futur de la région par le
prisme de la compétition entre les
partis politiques traditionnels est
quelque chose qui effectivement ne
fonctionne pas sais plus si je l'évoqué
plus tôt mais on a demandé il n'y a pas
très longtemps aux gens qu'elle était la
couleur politique de leur président de
deux régions la moitié ne savait pas
répondre donc de fait c'est un côté un
peu hors sol c'est à dire que c'est un
peu ça qu'on a eu à arbitrer ce soir et
les gens n'étaient pas au courant alors
de fait ils ne sont pas allés voter pour
la plupart d'entre eux ce qui n'était
pas au courant mais on voit pas sur le
scrutin régional effectivement les mêmes
phénomènes que l'on voit sur les
scrutins municipaux notamment celui du
mandat de trop ce qui me semblait certes
en tout cas pas d'énormes attentes
malheureusement en fait si les gens
continuent à se dire que la politique et
les mandats ça doit changer des choses
concrètes
je pense qu'on a du mal ça se
l'approprier on a du mal à se dire ce
que changerait le fait qu'une région ou
pas bascule de majorité y compris au
niveau du département donc si l'enjeu
des élections c'est ça et qu'on ne
perçoit pas dans un pays qui reste
attachée à la politique de ce pays
d'ailleurs qui ont montré qu'ils
seraient intéressés à la politique en
sortir du confinement
il ya quelque chose qui effectivement
est raté parce que justement roland nous
dit les maires les présidents de
départements et de régions n'ont pas les
mêmes relations qu un gouvernement avec
le français mais aujourd'hui
finalement le les français on a
paradoxalement une relation plus forte
avec le gouvernement même si c'est
parfois dans la répulsion qu'avec les
exécutifs régionaux
oui parce qu'il ya une exposition qui
est bien plus forte en particulier en
france où où le président de la
république et le et le la figure
centrale est presque unique delà du du
goût du gouvernement national et
alors je il faut effectivement traitée à
part les maires qui historiquement ont
des compétences qui sont bien identifiés
par les français ils savent à peu près
pour qu'elles pour quels sujets ils
doivent aller frapper à la porte de la
mairie mais sinon combien de français
sont capables de dire ce qu'elles sont
les compétences du conseil départemental
et à quoi servent les communautés de
communes et est donc je pense que c'est
moi un échec de la décentralisation
comme principe c'est-à-dire comme comme
volonté de rapprocher le gold le
gouvernement des citoyens que de la
confusion et de l'opacité de ceux de ce
partage qui est d'autant moins clair que
parfois ça se superposer que des
collectivités se font concurrence à
différentes strates pour pouvoir agir
et comme ça en bouche et les
fonctionnaires parce que pendant qu'on y
est ça peut jamais nuire j'ordonne
bardella qui était tête de liste du
rassemblement national en ile de france
est en train de prendre la parole on va
l'écouter je vous donne la parole
ensuite socio économiques auxquels notre
monde est confronté ce désintérêt d'une
partie croissante des français pour le
fonctionnement de nos institutions de
tout laisser personne indifférent et
doit collectivement nous interroger par
ailleurs les dysfonctionnements
gravissime d'organisation du scrutin
engage clairement la responsabilité du
pouvoir exécutif et du ministre de
l'intérieur chargé des élections
le silence assourdissant comme l'absence
totale de communication et d'information
du gouvernement dans l'organisation de
l'élection
la non livraison des professions de foi
pour des millions d'électeurs ont
engendré une faille sans précédent
laissant conclure à un scandale d'état
si chacun d'entre nous doit prendre sa
part de responsabilité dans l'abstention
massive qui gagne le pays
le ministre de l'intérieur ne peut se
terrer dans le silence devant un tel
sabotage et prendre ses responsabilités
je remercie les millions d'électeurs qui
ont porté leurs suffrages sur le
rassemblement national en ile de france
et partout ailleurs leur confiance nous
honore et nous oblige
je remercie enfin les centaines de
militants et candidats du rassemblement
national engagés partout en france
et bien souvent bénévolement pour faire
vivre la démocratie locale
la vague et le courant d'idées qui nous
porte ne serait-ce arrêté à la porte
d'un scrutin dénué d'intérêt pour une
majorité du pays
combattu souvent battus parfois abattus
jamais la mère de toutes les batailles
arrive ne lâchons rien je vous remercie
voilà on vient d'entendre jordan
bardella donc c'était un grand chef
vendée on interpellé la semaine dernière
vivement les électeurs assemblée
nationale maintenant on attaque le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est le
changement de change d'angle d'attaqué
là la stratégie de marine le pen
consistant à a réveillé ses électeurs en
les endettant sens pour qu'ils aillent
voter au second tour n'a pas été
couronné de succès donc il va falloir
passer à autre chose
déjà pendant cette semaine c'était une
des prises de position qui ne faisait
pas du tout l'unanimité
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
cafouillages dans le dans le dans
l'acheminement de tout ce qui était
profession de foi et son matériel de
vote
pour autant je pense que il faut bien
trouver des idées des raisons à la
défaite devant le bar de la trouve celle
là je pense que c'est plus une et d'un
prétexte que qu'autre chose il ya
effectivement c'est une réaction de d'un
parti qui déçus par ces
contre-performances on a d'ailleurs
entendu les mêmes choses chez plusieurs
vaincu ce soir la mise en cause de
l'organisation du scrutin
ça un bien bayeux aussi on a vu un bail
ou directement en a parlé d'un bayou qui
est en train de reprendre et ça va être
un peu compliqué de dire que ces
mécanismes de mots
un cheminement à ce point peser sur la
participation est ce que vraiment ça
aurait changé les choses alors peut-être
que symboliquement d'une certaine
manière le fait d'avoir pas pris grand
soin ovale même soin que d'habitude tous
a dit que collectivement n'accorde plus
d'importance que ça au vote ce serait
dramatique mais enfin voilà
l'accumulation les des petits quoique
peut être interprété comme ça finalement
par parler français les raisons de
l'abstention sont ailleurs qu'une
abstention qui a beaucoup plus concerné
les catégories populaires et les jeunes
et davantage peser sur le score de
rassemblement national c'est possible
encore que ce ne sont plus les plus
jeunes qui va être maintenant le plus
pour le rassemblement national
semble-t-il l'électorat rassemblement
national a un peu vieilli ce qui est
d'ailleurs peut-être pas sans lien avec
le caractère un peu trop installée que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur le dans le
paysage politique
c'est certainement pas tout casser
ressort là qui permettront au
rassemblement national à marine le pen
de trouver la clé pour se remettre dans
le débat dans la centralité du débat
finalement le le recul qu'on s'est
efforcé de prendre en disant il ya un
moment donné à voir un rapport entre ce
qu'on vote ce pourquoi on vote et
l'exécutif qu'il est question désigné
c'est vrai que si on réfléchit bien les
thématiques fort du rassemblement
national l'immigration identité là la
sécurité etc sont pas un central dans
les compétences des régions alors on
aurait pu s'en rendre compte plus tôt il
avait fait une très bonne performance
sur 2015 ils compteront performe mais
c'est peut-être ça aussi un peu ce qui
est en train de se passer dans cette
prise de distance des français avec la
politique c'est que si c'est pas tant
que ça l'objet finalement c'est un peu
sans objet les jeunes
nous dit jean paul les jeunes n'ont pas
voté mais c'est les jeunes de 18 à 35
ans oui conception assez large delà de
la jeunesse mais bien sûr qu'un rapport
immédiat
en gros il ya une génération pour qui le
vote reste un devoir quelque chose qui
fait partie du rituel civique il est
important d'accomplir
il ya une génération mais le prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur pour qui en fait
c'est aux politiques de mérite et
d'autres votes et c'est un changement de
perspective qui est totale
on va justement conclure cette soirée
21h56 est avec vous guillaume est avec
vous et manuelles et on va donner la
parole
à charlotte baril en deux bougies qui
scrutent depuis tout à l'heure avec
abnégation à toute déclaration résultats
développement un dernier point une
dernière synthèse avant de conclure
cette première partie de soirée
électorale
et avant de rejoindre nos partenaires de
la chaîne parlementaire et de public
sénat
vous restez avec nous merci vincent et
bien on retiendra qu'à l'échelle
nationale la droite arrive en tête avec
38,1 % des voix devant la gauche et
europe écologie les verts qui récoltent
34 8% des voix
le rassemblement le rassemblement
national est derrière avec 20 2% des
voix suivi de la république en marche
qui comptabilise 6 9% des voix console
concernant les résultats par région en
ile-de-france valérie pécresse est
largement réélu avec 45% des voix
la présidente sortante devance
l'écologiste julien bayou en deuxième
position avec 34 % des voix
valérie pécresse s'est exprimée tout à
l'heure une équipe de france de la
droite et du centre a émergé et j'y
prendrai toute ma part at elle affirmé
du côté des verts le secrétaire national
julien bayou estime que l'écologie est
la seule force en dynamique et qu'un
projet écologiste doit émerger pour la
présidentielle 2022
pour olivier faur premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste le ps a la
responsabilité de rassembler l'ensemble
de la gauche
autres résultats en région en paca le
républicain renaud muselier l'a emporté
face à thierry mariani du rassemblement
national avec 56% des voix contre 44%
la logique d'unité a gagné s'est
félicité renaud muselier en auvergne
rhône-alpes
laurent wauquiez est réélu facilement
avec 54 6% des voix dans les hauts de
france xavier bertrand est réélu sans
difficulté le président l ex et l'air
sortant est arrivé en tête du second
tour avec plus de 54% des voix après sa
large victoire dans les hauts de france
xavier bertrand a estimé que pour
redresser notre pays
il y à un préalable le rétablissement de
l'ordre et du respect en normandie le
centriste hervé morin est réélu haut la
main avec 42 2% des voix en nouvelles
aquitaine alain rousset
réélu pour un cinquième mandat avec 39
2% des voix en occitanie carole delga
est réélu face au rassemblement national
avec 58,5 % des voix en bretagne le
socialiste loïg chesnais-girard du parti
socialiste conserve la région dans le
grand est le président et l'air sortant
jean rottner est élu pour un deuxième
mandat avec 39% des voix et en corse
l'autonomiste et président sortant
gilles simeoni est réélu parmi les
prises de parole se soit on retrouve on
retiendra celle de marine le pen qui a
affirmé je cite malgré l'échec du
rassemblement national
elle donne rendez vous aux français dès
demain pour construire tous ensemble
l'alternance dont la france a besoin
on retiendra également les propos de
jean-luc mélenchon le leader de la
france insoumise qui s'est dit soulagé
de la lourde défaite du rassemblement
national en paca
il s'est félicité par ailleurs du
basculement de la réunion à gauche la
droite a en effet perdu la réunion la
candidate
huguette bello soutenue par la france
insoumise et le parti socialiste a
vaincu le président ex et l'air sortant
didier robert à la tête de l'île de la
réunion depuis 2010 bonne soirée
merci beaucoup charlotte il nous reste
une minute pour conclure allez on va
prendre deux minutes minutes chacun
votre bonne conclusion à la fois pour
cette soirée et puis également pour ce
scrutin il est bien la soirée pour finir
le profond désintérêt d'une partie des
électeurs sur ces élections qui à mon
avis pose une question fondamentale qui
est celle de la manière dont on met en
scène désormais la politique et confirme
aussi ce qui était évidemment un
événement majeur c'est la
contre-performance du rassemblement
national et notamment son incapacité à
gagner une région
et puis à voilà dans le paysage
politique si on se projette sur la
présidentielle
le
le fait est que les parties plutôt des
faits ce soir son second un leader très
identifiée emmanuel macron la france
jean luc mélenchon pour la france
insoumise et marine le pen
les partis qui s'en sortent bien les
partis traditionnels et notamment les
républicains sont ceux qui se cherchent
encore un leader c'est c'la le paysage
un peu paradoxal de vie politique entre
la région et les régionales et
présidentielle guillaume effectivement
nous avons assisté dans l'essai de tour
de ces régionales à un désintérêt
inédits des français pour la politique
et pourtant le paysage est
extraordinairement stable puisque tous
les présidents sortants
en tout cas en métropole sont en passe
d'être réélu
donc on peut dire qu'il n'ya pas eu d'
enseignement de cette élection si il y
en a eu 1 c'est que le le paysage
politique qu'on nous disait figé avec
effectivement un pays qui seraient
condamnés à ce tête-à-tête exclusif
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
est bien on s'aperçoit que l'histoire
n'est pas écrite que il ya des surprises
qu' il peut y avoir des plafonds de
verre
en tout cas il y en a eu 1 clairement
pour le rassemblement national et ça
montre que le jeu le jeu est ouvert et
en sable même si les républicains sont
loin d'avoir surmonté leur crise et le
traumatisme qu'a été 2010 est on peut
dire que ce soir la droite de
gouvernement est un petit peu rasséréné
et que macro et le pen subissent chacun
une double sanction c'est le sens de la
une du figaro à découvrir dans le
sur le site du figaro bien sûr et
également dans vos kiosques demain mais
également en pdf si vous ne l'êtes pas
abonné c'est l'occasion c'est l'occasion
de le faire vous verrez vous en aurez
pour votre argent et vous aurez
également l'éditorialde alexis brézet
pour qui à la présidentielle tout est
possible merci beaucoup
emmanuel on vous retrouve cette semaine
pour justement analysé la nouvelle vague
du baromètre kantar pour le figaro
magazine à paraître dans le figaro
magazine deux du week-end prochain et
demain et dit votre 1 du maine également
de chez kantar viendra commenter les
résultats avec y répondre à vos
questions avec bruno dresse est à partir
de 8h30 on retrouve guillaume touze dans
quelques minutes
23h à partir de 23h sur elle si vous
avez le choix vous pouvez retrouver
également et yves thréard à 23h
cornélien sur la chaîne parlementaire et
public sénat ba écoute et vous avez une
télévision vous avez un ordinateur vous
ouvrez les deux et voilà vous regarder
et ça le ça se passe ça se passera très
bien je vous remercie en tous les cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup
charlotte de nous avoir de fait
découvrir les coulisses du figaro merci
de nous avoir tenu au courant des
dernières déclarations d'avoir tenu au
courant les internautes du figaro et
merci également à ce que vous n'avez pas
vu parce que là on n'est pas dans ses
coulisses mais à l'équipe au tour de
maxime qu'une y est
jean pierre vandaele hubert et j'espère
n'oublier personne mais normalement tout
le monde est là sandrine salubre et léo
mayer marguerite aubry lors and mark sue
h
yoann da costa raphaël lazreg renan
l'aise blaise marie amélie boucher est
bien sûr encore ne le dira jamais assez
maxime kuni et jean-pierre vanhelder que
vous avez aperçu tout à l'heure
justement dans les coulisses du figaro
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
vous restez avec nous la soirée
électorale continue à la fois sur le
site du figaro et avec nos partenaires
de la chaîne parlementaire et de public
sénat
à très vite sur figaro life
[Musique]